ce qui se passe à tous de coutume par la
radio ou à la télé les journaux tout le
monde en face à l'autre mais oui ce
matin chez lui auprès sim attendait tous
trois font tuer par les eaux voici le
nouvel épisode tout le monde en bas
thierry ardisson
sa vie les porter
rien
les yeux
mine
mollien
un vrai public de télévision
les questeurs du soir ophélie winter
valérie lemercier
en club
josiane
ex spice victoria beckham
duy ploemel
et benjamin biolay
à lui de samedi soir
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout le
monde en parle l'émission pas comme les
autres vous connaissez le principe tout
le monde en parle alors tout le monde en
parle
vous connaissez l'équipe way seeland
avis
là monsieur
non ma vie mais attention attention
laurent ne m'habille ne passera pas et
des baptistes ce soir il ya trois pistes
non alors je suis retourné voir votre
pièce de théâtre beaucoup
d'améliorations sur le texte encore
mieux qu'au départ daniel russo et mieux
que l'acteur précédent sans comparaison
sans comparaison avec on peut dire son
nom
bernard farcy 1 mado maurin faut faire
attention qui lâchait la maintenant 86
ans oui si tu existantes comme ailier
non mais on fêtera ses 100 ans sur scène
on arrête un deal entre no way
et voilà c'est josem d'amour mado cette
pièce c'est parti pour être boing boing
quoi parce que ça quand tu aimes c'est
réjean la plus la cage aux folles que
boeing boeing
ouais alors les inconvénients du tout
dans les gens rient beaucoup et il
oublie complètement la troisième guerre
mondiale c'est marrant ça c'est un truc
qu'on n'avait pas prévu au départ
on est assez content c'est à dire que
les gens
vienne se changer les idées pendant
trois heures et c'est comme un lavage
intérieur tu vois c'était un peu office
de karcher c'est une canalisation à
linthal alors beaucoup d'e-mails
toujours beaucoup beaucoup du mail de
l'étranger grâce à tv5 que nous
remercions et que nous saluons ici
varsovie guadalajara au mexique
singapour saint pierre de saint pierre
et miquelon novossibirsk en sibérie
ils ont travaillé des gens qui envoient
des emails deux en russie place rigaud
ils ont la télé voilà à l'île maurice
aussi et puis en france bat sur tv5
eurodif de l'émission l'heure est écrite
en bas de l'écran
à nîmes l2 daniel r blé qui me dit
pourrais-tu annoncé la date de la venue
dans ton émission de la mer de jeane
manson
on cherche
et valérie de reims qui dit j'ai appelé
mon animal domestique ardisson car il
est tout noir et ckoi truelle domestique
un cafard
mais auriez une tradition dans cette
émission c'est de regarder chaque
semaine les romans de l'édition
précédente
ça s'appelle tout le monde en a parlé et
s'est préparé par jean luc morel magnéto
serge le plus grand moment de votre vie
là mon premier disque j'étais quoi votre
premier disque
c'est ce que ça veut dire
kylie ça veut dire [__] en ruine
préval un gros cul jennifer lopez
c'était après je la rencontre et la bbc
série cette boîte est changée samedi si
vous aime bien jean marie messier le
patron de vivendi universal mais il se
dit c'est un c'est un homme de télé
formidable lescure
mais c'est pas un patron tout le temps
nous partons dès qu'il a un coup dans le
cornet de chier dessus dernier man a
pris naissance dans le combat 73% des
femmes préfèrent faire l'amour le soir
au coucher
non non pas du tout bien alors oui oui
n'est pas non mais c'est quoi ces
attaques
j'aime le matin le matin le soir aussi
65% des femmes refusent des relations à
3 vous aussi ça vous intéresse pas non
vous n'avez jamais essayé
comment je rigolais la suivante
non mais des fois il ya des boisés
d'ailleurs thierry thierry land art
ouais
en plus il est imité leurs marques et
oui oui
vous êtes fan au château ce adorable
sont les pandas personne qui serait un
contente que tout dépend des goûts de
l'autre oui docile bien est-ce que vous
êtes seaux d'eau ça dépend de la
personne
bon
powermeter d'or on vous remercie le
comité des odeurs qui vous remet
officiellement les hordes donnèrent à
huy amont ou en aval genre de pub sur
rescue ans celui-là qui le méritent un
premier baiser
quel âge d'abord sur la bouche et
ashkénazes à part ça très bien avec qui
le prénom en rapidité vite non
cyril
première saudeau et fellation en même
temps j'ai la réponse à ça ils étaient
deux dans projet x déjà dans des femmes
sur canal
le reste de la semaine précédente
alors quand vous le savez la fin
d'émission viable à intel ce blind test
sera consacré ce soir au groupe de
filles en hommage à victoria beckham
l'ex spice girl qui est l'une de nos
invités ce soir pour arbitrer ce blind
test j'appelle un homme au dessus de
tout soupçon
moi j'avais les bordés
les
oui
la maison on va passer aux jeunes idiots
ce soir le jeu idiot c'est le limbo bon
vient alors le connaissez pas ces bimbos
c'est quoi c'est une contraction de
limay la bimbo note
il faut passer sous le bâton méline
accessoires à attention à ce pas pareil
musiquemag
this your soul et le bâton elle le prend
bien le bâti à l'air tiennent bien de
bâton attention bien bas bien bas sinon
ça va toujours bon toute addiction
il est content 1 musique maestro
oh
alors
patricia gagné bravo d'ici là
et donc titien comme titien s'il vous
plaît comme j'ai reçu beaucoup du mail
me disant que je faisais du favoritisme
pour thalia je vais vous offrir titia du
temps d'exposition télévisuel dont vous
allez vous mettre là à côté de laurent
baffie exposé médiatiquement pendant une
quinzaine de minutes voilà vous restiez
la voilà
j'accueille maintenant vers winter et
gilles paquet brenner
soir
paquet brenner ophélie winter bonsoir
j'ai gagné un 7 d'or bien aidé
bien au fait des essais pour pâques on
vous compare à loana vous êtes fait
brunir un peu les cheveux - vous savez
ah ouais non non je vais j'ai envie de
rester comme ça jean gilles paquet
brenner dont vous êtes le réalisateur
d'un film qui s'appelle les jolies
choses avec marion cotillard stomy bugzy
patrick bruel titoff et ophélie winter
voulez que je fasse le pitch vous le
faites
allez-y je vais faire le pit chercher ça
c'est l'histoire de deux soeurs
d
alors il ya deux soeurs jumelles y avait
une qui s'appelle lucie une qui
s'appelle marie mais elles ont
absolument rien à voir l'une avec
l'autre
lucie c'est un peu la bimbo d'infos
prête à tout pour réussir
marie c'est le côté obscur repliée sur
elle même complètement at his yann en
mouvement non en plus c'est prohibitif
comme qui voilà donc la deuxième mari
elle est complètement repliée sur elle
même elle est complètement bunkérisé et
un jour lucie est sollicité pour faire
un disque
elle sait pas chanter elle demande à
marie de prendre sa place
et pendant ce temps là lui six suicides
et marie est obligé d'endosser la
personnalité de sa soeur c'est à dire
une personnalité qui lui ressemble pas
du tout évidemment
alors il ya un témoin de l'histoire le
seul qui est au courant de la faire
c'est nicolas donc qui est un ami à un
ami de l'uci qui est jouée par stomy
bugzy voilà alors le rôle des deux
jumelles est interprétée par marion
cotillard patrick bruel il fait très
très bien d'ailleurs le patron d'une
maison de disques ophélie vous êtes une
égérie de la nuit dans ce film on peut
dire ça je me décrirais tu as et un
jeune noir
en outre sur un corner bien il s'est
tiré du livre de virginie despentes mali
tôt
le chinois
on avait beau se ressembler on était
très différente un soir elle est partie
pour toujours
je suis issu en lan
j'ai pris sa place
je connaissais pas le monde même si l
intéresser personne sans qu on s'en
souvient mais tu crois que tu vois c'est
de se faire passer pour peuvent faire
d'autres montants sujets abordés jahan
dira les lèvres il annonça je sais pas
je connais pas tu vois ce pas si
compliqué d'être code ne rasera pas les
jambes mais ton mec paumé qui est arrivé
demande et épilé nom et l'allemand tu
veux nous a dit pourquoi tu vas chanter
qu'est ce qui te motive fric mais c'est
sa voix qui compte mais que cet envoi
je passe mon temps à fermer ma gueule
jalousie qui t'intéresse pas vrai battue
continue à fermer ta gueule
tu veux faire quand même ce jusqu'au
bout tu veux faire comme elle je suis
fier de toi mais non envers toi
n'avait que tu collabores et jolies
choses
c'est pas pour les petite fille paumée
c'est pas à vendre ni à louer
tout ça c'est du vent et toi tes rêves
du vent c'est nîmes drogue
mes amitiés ce que la chair c'est
presque ça traite en toi sur ton pas
les joues les choses c'est autre chose
les jolies choses visibles à kevin r
c'est un fils d'une grande inventivité
sur le plan formel c'est très très rare
en france de voir des films aussi
sophistiquée sur plan visuel non ouais
mais en même temps il ya une lame de
fond là qui est en train d'arriver bon
enfin il ya ceux qu'on connaît
jan kounen mathieu kassovitz christophe
gornès moi je pense que je fais un peu
partie de la deuxième génération de ce
que j'appelle les réalisateurs cinéphage
et cinéphiles c'est à dire qu'ils ont
été élevés au cinéma américain et aussi
au cinéma français contre l'assurance de
sauter aussi dans les salles et de
bistrot en fait donc une évidence et que
l'on a grandi avec stallone phare
sénégal etc
et puis par ce biais là on est arrivé à
un cinéma un peu plus pointu et et voilà
mais j'ai pas fait d'école j'ai pas fait
tout ça quoi c'est un moyen métrage qui
s'appelait le marquis un qui avait déjà
eu pas mal de succès qui avait été très
remarquée et dans le film la chance que
vous avez c'est que tous les acteurs
soient participation parce qu'il croyait
au projet oui enfin le marquis c'est un
peu une histoire de fou c'est un truc
que je me suis levé un matin jeudi dans
quinze jours on va faire un film et en
traitant ya patrick bruel si bungie qui
se sont trouvés dedans mais one le besco
vanessa des mots et puis des amis à moi
tenir mais ni macho bull et mais là je
suis en train de le remonter
et pour le ressortir après je pense
directement en vidéo et ce qui est bien
c'est que ça m'a permis de bach on se
rend compte tout ce qu'on commence à
travailler ensemble et pouvoir
poursuivre après sur les jolies choses
alors à une semaine du tournage vous
aviez toujours pas d'actrice pour
interpréter votre ange noir
pourquoi vous avez choisi ophélie
finalement j'ai un peu forcé en fait moi
j'ai un copain qui m'appelle j'étais à
saint tropez au chapiteau et qu'il ya un
rôle super pourtant il faut que tu
appelles les metteurs en scène donc
j'appelle gilles il me demande d'en
monter à paris je remonte darbas et je
le supplie de me prendre pour faire ce
rôle parce que c'était un symbole très
trash et que j'avais envie de faire un
truc comme ça pour changer enfin et j'ai
un petit peu j'ai un peut violer c'est
ce que j'aime bien dire ça non mais
c'est vrai il disait tout le temps je
voudrais une sorte de fait les winter
leurs geôliers quelqu'un qui le dit
pourquoi tu prends pas ophélie winter
tout simplement
et voilà ça fait la blague il à la vraie
ophélie dans son film avait une chanson
du film qui est vachement bien
les jo
5 sens d'axel en noir très belle très
belle chanson qui va être un tube en
plus non c'est bien alors on s'est dit
c'est la forme n'ont jamais déclaré
vous avez déclaré le plus difficile dans
ce métier c'est de durer j'étais
tellement jeunes au départ et puis il a
fallu que je réalise ce qui m'arrivait
ensuite tout s'emballe et ça peut être
violent ouais
et c'est vrai que pour vous tout s'est
mis en marche en même temps là la musica
télévision c'est que ça a été très
rapide et très violent non c'est parti
en flammes
c'est un peu à cause de vous en même
temps je préfère le dire les gens ne le
savent pas mais j'avais fait une
émission est mise en doute dans le jury
a on vous voit vous m'aviez mis dans le
jury d'une émission que vous produisiez
et donc quelqu'un de m6 marbre remarquez
ce jour là et m'a proposé d'autres
émissions et après tout est parti comme
ça et c'est vrai que là j'ai fait un
break les deux dernières années et que
c'est pendant ces deux dernières années
que j'ai réalisé ce qui m'était arrivé
on va voir l'émission on parlait
peut-être peut-être qu'on trouvera un
détient classé dans ses classes pendant
une dizaine d'années elle fait lit tu
nous feras pas un album dubois en était
simple pour l'instant les 45 ans et un
album en préparation offert un look sans
dire en outre à août
est-ce que évidemment comme c'est prévu
on aura quelques titres de prins dessus
et n'aura pas 40 12 il y en aura deux
voire trois bon d'accord et pour la
rentrée j'ai appris qu'à priori tu
devais peut-être chanter un peu au
zénith en première partie de certains
artistes voient c'est pour l'instant on
va voir c'était la première apparition
de koné winter et à la télévision
elle avait été choisie pour un point
devant le jury effectivement de la coupe
du monde de la séduction c'est ça la
comédie la séduction et puis voilà et
c'est laurent ce petit sur m6 qui vous
accusent a remarqué et qui a décidé de
vous faire faire date et l'heure tout a
démarré en même temps il y avait l'album
il y avait là il y avait la télé c'était
très rapide ça a été a été fou et
j'étais un peu dépassé par les
événements pendant un mois ou deux j'ai
dû prendre un peu le melon et après je
me suis retombée c'est un pied très
speed vous étiez surmédiatisé à un
moment on peut le dire moi c'était un
peu et je sais pas si vous vous souvenez
quand on était petits y avait des
bouquins qui s'appelait martine à la
plage du ski j'avais un peu l'impression
d'être martin dans la presse jeune
importe quoi au fait que monoprix
ophélie fait tout ce qui est fait
n'importe quoi wen jiabao ophélie au
revoir on va paraître votre vue
ah oui
alors vous êtes né en 1974 est la fille
du chanteur hollandais david alexandre
winter et de kathy winters mannequin à
l'époque et qui est aujourd'hui votre
agent rect les parents se séparent quand
vous avez deux ans et vous allez vivre
donc en france arrivée en france et
vivra neuvy et votre père s'en va
habiter aux usa et vous dit en parlant
de lui qu'il était lobotomisés du coeur
oui parce qu'en fait j'ai compris super
tard en fait quand mon grand père est à
juste avant que mon grand père s'en
aille
enfin m eur sur son lit d'hôpital il m'a
raconté un truc est parce qu on est juif
donc et dans la famille quand la les
nazis sont arrivés en hollande mais mes
grands parents ont placé mon père dans
une famille catholique et plus les nazis
se rapprochait plus les familles passé
mon père de famille en famille comme ça
donc il a dû faire cinq ou six familles
et du coup il a recréé ça quand il a été
adulé il fait des gosses partout je
découvre des frères des soeurs hollande
en belgique c'est n'importe quoi s'est
il a été très généreux de sa graine mon
papa c'est votre mère que vous avez levé
cathy donc prêt d'argent quand vous
étiez enfant j'aurais pas du tout je me
souviens de trucs le pire dont je me
souvienne c'est quand on était à l'école
on louait on avait un appartement et on
le louer pendant qu'on était à l'école
on aller habiter chez des copains
pourquoi mr est un peu d'argent pour
nous au fil et à manger dans cet axe
était souvent les les pâtes et les
patates
ouais pas temps de manger de la viande
c'était la fête mais bon man a assuré
l'assuré et malgré tout vous avez quand
même le sens du spectacle chevillée au
corps parce que vous faites votre
premier disque à l'âge de 6 ans oh mais
là j'étais pas consciente 1 la mère qui
est je voulais chanter donc elle met un
peu déguiser et faire ce truc là et
j'étais super en colère après elle mais
on a récidivé à l'âge de 12 ans et là
j'ai dit c'est suffisant tous mes
copains à l'école ce côté de moi je dis
là c'est bon je dis à tous mes potes on
verrai quand je serai grande ça m'a mis
la rage du quand je serai grande je
serai un indice que ça marchera ya
l'école c'était assez dur quand vous
étiez petit
laissez pas vos repos pour dix balles
vous arranger les affaires de vaud de
vos camarades d'école j'ai en fait
j'étais grande en sais quoi maintenant
peu maternelle en primaire
j'étais assez grande par rapport aux
autres donc je casser la gueule pour d'y
prendre aux toilettes je faisais des
spectacles jeux rival est content de mes
copines et après ça s'est retourné
contre moi parce qu'au lycée j'étais une
naine pendant trois ans jusqu'à ses 40
et là c'était plutôt mois pour tabasser
la plus petite de la classe et c'est un
petit peu une métaphore de votre vie
parce que finalement tout le monde va
vers vous et puis après vous vous
retrouvez un peu là c'est ce qui vient
de se passer pendant deux trois ans vous
retrouvez un peu la naine de la classe
mais c'est plus c'est bien ça fait du
bien de se prendre les petites claques
dans la tranche comme ça en devient bien
je te montre et vous prenez votre
revanche à l'époque où les grandes
gigues ne sont plus à la mode et c'est
la fin dès la fin des plates et vous
avec contre 1 ça m'a sauvé la vie ça
j'ai commencé à être mannequin cette
époque là je partis de chez ma mère atx
pas j'avais 17 ans jugent être mannequin
est un petit peu rigoler parce que sa
tâche par un mètre 68 et j'avais des
saints triple de jeux récents de tour de
poitrine c'est vrai ça m'arrivait d'un
coup en plus jusqu'à 17 ans j'étais
comme la table mais c'est vrai c'est que
s'ils perdent mène au long sur la plage
voilà je fais toi toi je vais te dis ça
pendant des années
alors à neuilly sur le même palier que
vous habitez les frères mc h
eliana qui vous dit vous avez un
physique de chanteuse les phrases de
films c'est à toi tu veux faire des
chapeaux et non pas encore le sommet et
oui donc le comité c'était mon voisin et
que je voyais sortir son chien depuis
des années je pensais que c'était
quelqu'un de bien donc j'ai commencé à
travailler avec lui et ses frères s'est
avéré que ça c'est pas super bien passé
donc j'ai fait un divorce de producteurs
qui a duré un an et qui m'a empêché de
chanter pendant un an
non non vous n'êtes pas chanter j'ai
profité pour faire de la télé sur m6
mais en expliquant quand même à qui
voulait l'entendre que ce n'était pas le
but de votre vie excepté justin un
passage c'est l'époque aussi de votre
relation avec prins alors on n'a jamais
su ce qui s'est passé parce qu'un jour
je vous ai posé la question dans un
journal et vous m'avez dit le premier
qui parle doit payer chez plus combien
1000 $ à l'autre c'est pas vrai j'avais
une petite amourette avec tryo
prescription maintenance location pour
en parler foot oui c'est fini
ouais les nombreux voyages à minneapolis
ans mais j'arrive ici me dire faire la
téloche toi j'étais encore à l'école
j'avais 17 ans j'étais encore l'école
ouais ça commençait vachement tôt il le
vendredi soir quand j'ai quitté l'école
je prenais l'avion je faisais paris
boston boston minneapolis et je revenais
le dimanche inutile de dire que les
devoirs et les courges n'importe quoi
c'est pas ça ça a duré longtemps ça fait
que vous n'avez jamais aventuré galabru
t'aurais pas redoublés non plus
ça c'était en fait le quatrième essai
discographique et vul trois échecs avant
et c'est génial parce que vous dites
finalement au point où j'en suis
maintenant je me suis tellement planter
autant faire ce qui me plaît
glorifié du rôle assez l'idée que vous
aviez et dieu vous a aidé apparemment
aide toi le ciel t'aidera un truc comme
ça je sais pas mais j'avais vraiment
envie de parler de ça je me suis toute
façon personne ça n'intéresse personne
dieu mes copains quand je leur ai fait
lire ma chanson homonyme et attend les
n'importe quoi et finalement ben voila
c'était la belle surprise et alors là
c'est un peu le début du délire parce
que vous déclarez à l'issue de ce succès
j'ai toujours eu l'impression d'être
prédestiné bon jusque là d'avoir une
boule de feu au dessus de la tête
oui à l'époque j'avais un peu de mal à
m'exprimer donc non mais c'est vrai j'ai
pas une boule de feu mais j'avais fait
litres enfin je peux pas en parler là
mais qu'est ce qui s'était passé j'ai
fait une séance d'hypnose une fois pour
arrêter de fumer et c'est à dire est que
ça va pas marcher ça peut marcher mais
c'est tant mieux et j'ai lu c'est une
image comme ça de joaillier les gens
comme des boules de feu c'était en fait
c'étaient les âmes qui étaient comme des
petites boules de feu qui parlaient en
faisant de la télépathie fin on avait
l'impression au moment où vous n'aviez
aucune maîtrise de votre carrière si
vous faisiez un petit peu tout ce qu'on
vous demandez quand j'étais choix assez
aléatoire n'est pas connue et en rêve
depuis que tu es petit tu fais n'importe
quoi c'est à dire à une fois que
j'aurais pu faire une ouverture de
prisunic avec un string panthère
j'aurais fait n'importe quoi pour être
connu ce que j'en rêvais et comme ça un
peu marcher je me suis dit ma mère me
disait tout le temps tu profites profite
parce que ça peut très bien s'arrêter
demain donc je me disais [__] [__]
vite oui alors oui toi oui et je vous
retrouve à dire oui à tout le monde à
faire naître ce qui n'avait ni queue ni
tête
ce que je ne sais plus aujourd'hui et
cette histoire avec mc solaar s'est
terminé comme en bas comme une rupture
de gens normaux c'est une rupture n'a
pas à faire ouais normal quoi contribuer
avec en même temps cinq ans et demi
ed winter comme vous êtes croyante on va
vous faire une interview croyance en
qu'est ce qui se passait mais qui sont
des gens par ces gens roulent à qui des
six batteries sur ce jour d'école ces
barbus papy tu vas pas d'accord cela dit
on peut encore s'exprimer
bien à l'interview croyances ophélie
winter est ce que vous croyez en dieu
oui oui oui
quand vous étiez enfant au lieu de vous
créer une espèce de vies parallèles
comme font les enfants avec des
personnages et où vous souhaitez dieu
moi c'est en fait j'ai compris encore
plus tard que c'était le manque de père
etc en fait au lieu de parler à mon père
je parlais à dieu tout les voilà j'avais
besoin d'un homme dans la vie voilà
est-ce que vous croyez à l'amour oui oui
j'y crois encore ouais vous avez été
assez tardive parce que votre premier
garçon où vous l'avez connu quand
j'avais 17 ans un niveau des relations
sexuelles oui oui j'étais pas j'étais un
mec
j'étais vachement mec je traînais avec
mon frère ouais tu vois que tu es filles
fassent l'amour à quel âge tu n'es pas
prête à l'emploi
j'avais pas de sens jusqu'à 17 ans quant
à ben voila je n'ai pas le matos je vous
cherchez un père pour un bébé je cherche
un père même un homme pour moi d'abord
cela les arrange personne et après
éventuellement pour un bébé
ouais vous dites il faut quelqu'un qui
m'aime pour mon âme et pas seulement
pour mon physique parce que dans 20 ans
j'ai le cul par terre et je fais des
noeuds avec mes seins c'est vrai que
c'est pas très encourageant quand même
bien non c'est pas terrible non mais
c'est que c'est dur à trouver un mec je
suis paranoïaque fait avec les mecs j'ai
l'impression que le jour je vais être
enceinte ils vont aller sauter à droite
à gauche on ne sait pas ce qui va se
passer
cherchez quoi comme genre de mec j'ai
pas de genre c'est un mec avec qui je me
marre qu'ils soient gentils qui m'aime
moi c'est tout le monde peut poser sa
candidature j voilà vous avez le site de
tout perdre en partie sur france 2
pourtant c'est la question de la fiche
numéro 69 c'est vous qui me poser une
question
les rôles sont inversés je vous écoute
69 questions thierry rv oui ok posez moi
une question en fait dit est-ce que tu
m'aimes j'aurais voulu être la vérité
c'est que j'aurais aimé être ton
pygmalion on en parlera est ce que vous
croyez en vous maintenant oui depuis peu
est ce que vous croyez aux anges
gardiens ouais j'espère vraiment devient
du gardien c'est en fait en fait c'est
un autre un autre nous dans un espèce de
l'univers parallèle moi c'est comme ça
aux fantômes
ouais à superman non non non au père
noël non plus maintenant au pouvoir de
pikachu way à mort vous voyez à l'effet
des crèmes antirides
non mais j'espère je me plais à y croire
jean de placebo chamakh ça marche
la réincarnation vous y croyez ouais
vous voudrez vous réincarner en quoi
vous en chat pour être caressé bouffer
dormir je croyais à céline dion
et alors tu as d'autres questions alors
merci joker c'est gilles qui répond
ouais ouais quand on répond pas ça passe
à la personne d'à côté c'est un rituel
si je dis non à ma première télé je
crois pas en sell-in j'ai l'air con
comme tu dis oui aussi est ce que vous
croyez à la mort d'elvis presley
oui oui pas qu'il a éclaté sur les
chiottes qui prenait tellement de cachet
de gens pour dormir pour manger pour
maigrir pour l'un qu'il a éclaté je suis
croyant la fidélité dans le couple et
j'ai non maintenant moi oui j'essaie
d'être moi je suis fidèle à mes attentes
je te jure ça va pas nous
les sous croyait l'amour sans sexe non
non quand on aime il faut que sa as
vous croyez au sexe sans amour ouais est
ce que voudrait que patrick fiori peut
se remettre de son aventure avec lara
fabian qu'à voir d'imagés trop dur cette
crise est ce que vous croyez qu'on peut
faire l'amour cinq fois de suite
ah oui je le comparais confie chantal
deux garçons l'info candidats l'on
dépense
mais je lis je sais
gilles paquet brenner
les jolies choses
alors quelques emails avant de continuer
christophe de méricourt qui dit ma femme
et moi on fait souvent l'amour devant
ton émission
pourrais tu lui dire que la fellation
est une chose naturelle dans le couple
j'aurais peut-être une chance grâce à
toi non c'est pas un truc naturel
l'activation
c'est un truc contre nature autre email
chérie si tu passes ce message en
mentionnant mon prénom est ma ville elle
me fait la totale banon
j'accueille maintenant valérie lemercier
merci ça va pas mal
est ce que pour vous la fellation est
une chose naturelle dans le couple ne
sais pas ce que c'est c'est bien ce que
je disais c'est la nature telle attaque
bille en tablier et voilà alors vous
êtes déjà vu dans cette émission nous
raconter votre vie la drogue la
prostitution la zoophilie on va pas
recommencer à chaque fois j'ai
simplement rappeler un petit peu votre
passé qui est brillant valérie lemercier
vous avez grandi à gonfreville en
seine-maritime avec trois soeurs départ
en exploitant agricole à 18 ans vous
monter à paris vous fait le
conservatoire et les petits boulots
comme vendeuse aux galeries lafayette
nous a beaucoup aidés par la suite pour
caricaturer les gens vous débutez au
piano zinc un bar homosexuel du marais
et puis vous commencez à faire des one
man show de la télévision du cinéma pour
un premier one man show vous obtenez un
molière en télévision vous fait lady
palace dans la série de jean michel
ribes au cinéma milou en mai avec louis
malle les visiteurs le numéro un vous
obtenez un césar du meilleur second rôle
vous refusez le second mais vous faites
un album avec bertrand burgalat et
ensuite vous commencez à réaliser des
films de pub et puis des films de cinéma
dont le génial le derrière qui
caricaturent la gauche caviar gay et là
vous obtenez pour troisième one man show
une récompense qui est encore un molière
voilà
pris en commun
c'est l'argument réconfort aux cons
bien où en sont vos rapports avec la
promotion à la télévision ça va je suis
là vous dites on ne pose jamais les
bonnes questions
non il ya des mauvaises surtout peut-on
rire de tout ouais du bien de rien avec
ce qui se passe en ce moment
oui c'est vrai que c'est vrai que c'est
la troisième guerre mondiale j'ai vu un
alors donc vous êtes ici pour votre
troisième one man show celui qui a été
pendant six mois aux folies bergères et
qui maintenant part en tournée en
province avec un olympia l'olympia c'est
du 11 au 15 décembre et la tournée c'est
dans toute la france jusqu'en mars 2002
puis en tournée en ce moment ouais c'est
comment faire avec les mains je sais pas
cette voie
6 novembre à clermont-ferrand dans le 63
le 8 à vichy sait dans quoi vichy je ne
sais pas le 9 à nevers dans le coin à 9
heures à 9 heures le 10 à bourges à
bourges fait beau chez les bourges et
après en belgique en belgique bien sûr à
liège à bruxelles
voilà mais on regarde à quoi ça
ressemble mallet auxerre qui pensait non
mais sa volonté
je m'appelle son vin kouté j'ai 19 ans
je suis élève dans une école de tourisme
j'ai inscrit que je cherche un stage
d'enluminure
non mais ça m'arrive aussi de m'amuser à
un merci je sais ce que c'est avec
l'humour je pratique c'est pas dit qu'on
verrait la drogue
c'est un gros challenge ce que tu sais
si c'est vrai que juliette c'est
juliette juliette de roméo et juliette
en fait elle aime pas romeo non parce
que sa grande soeur de ma copine daphné
elle dit qu'en fait elle fait l'amour
avec le chanteur d'alibaba com
quinze des 100 marches à mort vous en
foutez vous ai pas besoin de faire de la
promo n'est ce pas serait bien je suis
très contente d'être parti en tournée
très contente et c'est tout ce que tu
détestes de convoi détruit
c'est tout ce que j étais simplement il
ya un tel décalage c'est à dire que on a
tellement pas d'image qui ont fini par
passer des trucs où je suis en train de
doubler tarzan ou comme ça que c'est
d'ailleurs très mauvaise qualité ce
qu'on vient de voir c'est juste mon
petit caméscope qui a filmé un soir aux
folies bergères donc j'en ai assez des
petits vous mais c'est vrai qu'il n'ya
pas de cassettes n'y a pas de spectacle
n'est pas filmé oui c'est ça ça vous
fait jamais de cassettes de vos
spectacles y aura pas de trace non il y
en a 2 aucun des trois camps vous serez
mort tu vois plus rien voilà il y aura
plus rien il y aura ok voilà c'était
comme ça ouais c'est la vie alors c'est
un spectacle est très au point des
textes très ciselée très très juste
autour d'une douzaine de personnages qui
ont tous un point commun c'est d'être
des victimes on peut dire non un petit
peu c'est un petit peu mal barré le
personnage typique lemercier la burj
catho qui ramassent des cormorans
mazoutés capelle sa soeur bene ça c'est
la berline mais ouais bah bill ça c'est
un classique
oui c'est à dire que j'avais pas fait
dans le précédent de bourges comme ça
mais là je les reprises ça m'amusait de
la mettre dans un autre contexte de la m
en bretagne c'est surtout qu'elle a une
soeur qui est très dépressive et qu'elle
est très méchante
il ya une vieille défoncé je n'ai pas
assez joué
non non on l'a droguée où elle est assez
j'avais née et s'est fait stériliser en
avril 95 par ses parents mais bon allez
malbar merci une paysanne une prof de
danse russe une étudiante très méchante
et puis des passages en string comme on
vient de voir le pen je veux que ces
normes le belge veuf qui raconte de son
fils comment sa mère était bonne ouais
ouais nférieure ça les gens je n'avais
c'est à dire que c'est très drôle
d'ailleurs parce que je suis en tournée
depuis un mois plus je suis dans le nord
plus ça parle aux gens c'est à dire
carrément via des gens j'ai joué à
maubeuge l'autre jour c'est vrai que les
gens sont très près de lamu la belgique
dans toutes les expressions beige
donc j'ai hâte de le jouer à bruxelles
en belgique
vous n'êtes toujours pas mariés vous non
plus non c'est lors de la mais qu'est-ce
que vous avez des fils
et puis une mecque non c'est vrai ya
plus jusqu'à zélés bien il reste que des
marionnettes dans l'aisne nous marquons
vous allez perdre et jamais vous marier
mais si j'aimerais bien mais je sais pas
fini ouais vous voulez lancer un appel à
la télé non non pas du tout non surtout
pas non non c'est sûr parce que vous
savez comment ça marche on conçoit des
nombreux incroyable mais vrai nom mais
c'est bon aussi j'ai reçu une lettre
aujourd'hui on me demandait des photos
avec des tapes tenues différentes
est-ce que vous pouvez mettre des tas de
tenues différentes et m'envoyer les
photos non non mais je fais pas
d'alliance maintenant on fait des non
plus non ça va ça va venir tout cela
doit venir tout seul
les andalous
maintenant
vingt six fourgons bugs
donc bon soir moi ça champion du monde
98 vainqueur de l'euro 2000 capitaine de
l'om et vous avez déclaré dans france
football
je refuse toutes les émissions de
télévision sauf celle de thierry
ardisson
vous êtes la meilleure donc c'est normal
que cette saison
c'est
vous avez le crâne rasé c'est pas de la
coquetterie
ah non c'est parce que vous avez
commencé à perdre vos cheveux de 28 ans
vous perdez vos cheveux à l'âge de 28
ans 1
non j'ai commencé plus tôt ma 21 22 ans
après c'était surtout par nécessité que
je me suis rasé la tête mais quand je
les fais au départ on a cru que j'étais
malade et donc de tester pas tendance à
l'époque vous dites maintenant c'est
fait je n'avais pas que tout le monde
croyait que j'étais leucémiques mais il
y en a encore pour qui malheureusement
c'est pas une mode d'être chaud
c'est
c'est vous
chanson
ce
pour lutter informer soutenir les
malades
la ligue contre le cancer spot donc pour
la ligue contre le cancer
c'est là près crozemarie donc les gens
essayent de redemander de l'argent
français après ce qui s'est passé
heureusement que vous êtes là il faut
vraiment des champions du monde parce
que messi soit il ce qui place est
tellement odieux
ouais sinon c'est vrai que c'était
odieux et c'est vrai que ça beaucoup de
gens sont posé des questions mais je
pense que la ligue contre le cancer a
vraiment envie de redonner un coup de
boost à l'appel des notamment de fin de
l'argent quoi et c'est resté important
de le faire parce que on a banalisé
cette maladie on a observé qu'on a
beaucoup parlé du sida et notamment et
que on oublie un petit peu le cancer et
qu'il faut surtout pas oublier que c'est
quand même la maladie qui tue plus de
personnes et que c'est important de le
faire moi ça m'a touché ça me touche
encore plus parce que dans ma famille je
l'avais grand père qui est mort du
cancer votre père qui persiste depuis
quatre ans depuis quatre ans qui va
sortir un hôpital parce que ben ça va ça
va un peu mieux et c'est vrai que ça ça
me touche et que je suis tous les jours
à l'hôpital et que j'en vois tous les
jours qui souffrez
c'était bien de le faire mais c'était
pas seulement pour mon père c'était pour
tout le monde et je pense qu'il faut si
bing fabien nicolas et appuyer cette
thèse on va revenir au football j'ai vu
le maire à la télévision complètement
effondrée parce que les clubs étrangers
dans lesquels jouent les français
veulent pas les laisser aller jouer en
équipe de france
oui c'est vrai que c'est vrai qu'il ya
un match en australie la semaine
prochaine et que on se doit de présent
puisque là le sélectionneur et la
fédération française se rappelle à nous
et ça gêne certains certains clubs parce
que notamment arsenal puisque c'était
arsène wenger qui est qui avait commencé
cette cette polémique qui est devenue
une pétition
auprès des clubs de tous les clubs ou
auxquelles appartiennent les joueurs
l'équipe de france mais gérer que nous
on n'a pas tellement notre mot à dire
qu'il n'ya pas une règle de la fifa qui
oblige les clubs étrangers à rendre les
joueurs nationaux 1,6 à l'équipe de
france pour les matches interdit
complètement là le droit à huit matches
dans la saison avec l'équipe de france
c'est donc sur celui ci sera le dernier
et le huitième et dernier
et c'est vrai que beaucoup de clubs ont
notamment arsenal ils ont la ligue des
champions le championnat les coupes
nationales et donc pour certains les
joueurs l'équipe de france et ça pose
problème mais bon on mais c'est un choix
du sélectionneur c'était toujours pour
nous je pense à l'honneur de son équipe
de france on ne peut pas trop non plus
râler quand on doit aller où elle est
reconnue menace faire alors on va parler
du match france algérie où la
marseillaise a été sifflé ou le stade a
été envahi vous vous aviez été remplacé
à la pause par mikaël silvestre mais
vous êtes retourné sur le stade dans
costume cravate et en boitant et vous
avez gueuler quand même fait partie de
ce congolais
vous dites on nous fait prendre des
risques pour des raisons politiques pour
montrer nos bonnes relations et nous
envie de de retrouver certaines amour
avec avec les algériens on avait
organisé ce match mais moi j'ai pas
critiquer le fait d'avoir ce match au
contraire c'était bien de le faire mais
c'était certainement pas le moment quoi
après le 11 septembre les attentats
terroristes y avait trop de symbole
sur le terrain réunis et on en a fait
vraiment une affaire politique et donc
aux saveurs moi je m'attendais dès jeudi
puisque le match a eu lieu le samedi à
ce qui nous arrive est un problème
beaucoup plus grave que ce qui est
arrivé est donc samassa moi ça m'a gêné
je les dis après après les trois jours
de réflexion je les dis
je pense que ce match avait pas lieu
d'être et surtout que l'organisation
était complètement inexistante
on a retrouvé des piques en bois sur le
terrain et que leur suffit qu'un qatari
rendre sur le terrain et enfonce le pic
en bois sur lilian thuram par exemple
été le dernier à sortir voyez tout le
monde est rentré dont vous d'ailleurs et
thuram est resté là thuram est resté
ouais ils sont restés il ya quelqu'un
qui sont restés cocon compenser qui
avait pas de problème mais c'est vrai
qu'il n'a pas vu il n'y a pas eu de
problème mais il aurait pu en avoir un
et on serait peut-être en train de plus
rien des joueurs l'équipe de france à
l'heure actuelle
donc c'est vrai que moi j'ai aussi
ressenti ça comme dans une insécurité
totale en tout cas et j'ai demandé à
michael parce que psychologiquement
j'étais atteinte par pas partout ça que
j'avais ma femme était à paris avec les
enfants j'avais dit vous y allez pas
vous allez pas au match et que j'avais
senti qu'il y avait il ya les avoir un
problème j'ai pensé que madame buffet
était et est responsable de tout ça et
qu'elle devait être tenu comme
responsable
vous avez vu ce match sauf événement
c'est quoi j'ai trouvé ça nul ce soir ce
n'est pas le moment de faire ce genre de
connerie n'a pas d'heure par quoi je
pensais vraiment qu'on mélange est
justement comme tu le dit le sport et le
moment est là et la politique c'est
vraiment non
ouais mais ça c'est en plus le match
était un beau match donc c'était contre
le dollar était assis près de la fin
quoi rêvez-vous non regarde jamais le
foot
ah bon vous regardez pas le faut dit non
pour ce que vous avez pas vous marier
non mais attendez
et même chez les jeunes femmes qui
regardent le foot je vous le dis moi
dans tous les cas n'est quand même je
suis je suis allé à la finale de coupe
du monde il y avait des types avait
maquillé en bleu blanc rouge comme ça
qui j'ai fait la bise j'étais tout
maquillé en bleu blanc rouge
vous avez vu franck alors oui j'ai vu
franck bien sûr c'est comme ça que je
connais bien quand jospin en tant qu on
siffle la marseillaise et qui quittent
pas le stade ça vous fait quel effet
vous moi le fait que l'on soit sifflé
je m'y attendais je veux dire que dans
le monde du football
le respect gérer d'une nation où le
respect des joueurs simplement des
individus n'existe pas je suis rentré en
france
j'ai eu quand j'étais enfant j'étais en
angleterre on disait souvent mais
pourquoi les champions du monde revienne
pas en france ce serait bien qu'ils
reviennent et je reviens est tous
contents et c'est vrai que je vais sur
certains stades et j'entends mon nom
suivi d'un an d'oiseaux ou quoi
récemment d'oiseaux ouais donc c'est
vrai de se faire traiter de
d'enculés faut le dire c'est sur un
terrain de football c'est vrai et ça
méritait j'ai rien fait je pense que
quand on a un respect quand on joue au
golf
quand je jouais au golf quand on joue au
tennis ça ne vous traite d'enculé
bizarrement alors que c'est bon non mais
voilà donc c'est dommage parce que bon
c'est vrai qu'il ya pas que des
intelligences sur un terrain de sur un
terrain de football et dans les tribunes
et que c'est dommage de se faire traiter
comme ça quand on est blessé gens là ont
fait là
bon alors le 20 octobre
bah vous étiez suspendu pour om lille
suite à l'incident qui avait eu le 13
octobre sur m om faisait mauvais
caractère je suis pas facile mais non je
pense pas avoir mûri caractère surtout
sur ce coup là où je suis copain j'ai
pas fait une faute du match seul joueur
ça va être le seul joueur dans le monde
à se faire expulser sans avoir commis
une seule faute pendant tout le match
c'est quand même assez rigolo ouais
enfin bon faut accepter édition de
l'arbitrage est un peu soupe au lait
quand même c'est vrai nom aurait
certainement assez longue à strasbourg
par exemple je sais pas mais vous aviez
sorti un journaliste de l'équipe des
vestiaires à coup de genou dans le
ventre et quand on vous ai demandé
pourquoi à coup de genou dans le ventre
de vie parce que j'ai la cheville
vouziers
je ne fais jamais pour rien que jamais
pour rien il m'a il m'a
il apparaît tellement n'a pas traité de
reculer mais il m'a cassé et m'a cassé
pendant une année
l'année de la qualification +96 quand je
suis en équipe de france
et puis bon on m'avait demandé nos
instances fédérales ne pas bouger
donc j'ai pas bougé jusqu'au moment où
on a été comme ça on s'est qualifiés et
à ce moment-là bombe à sa valeur et un
choeur allers venues elle est venue
j'avais demandé par entrer j'avais été
gentilles avait prévenu demandez pas
rentrer mais il a rigolé un coup de
boule les foules
voilà brise ou le physique est battu
mais je réalise non non ça ne mérite pas
trop sur les parlers les journalistes
qui écrivent des soupes ou pas bien
méchant joue c'est tellement nul que je
ne préfère pas répondre ouais jamais de
coups de boules je vais tout jaloux dans
le ventre non mais c'est de la boxe thaï
samassa me défouler un sac de frappe sur
ma terrasse non je suis énervé je vais
mettre des petits coups et après je
redescends moi j'aimerais bien mais j'ai
pas de terrasse non moi je viens l'hôtel
pour l'instant oui j ai décidé d opter
pour des terrains
maintenant je peux pas me les payer si
vous souffrez pas d'un manque de
confiance on vous en demande de
reconnaissance mois d'argent chambre
d'hôtel avec une permanence à normand
par l'argent des tourneurs il a souffert
à une époque sur l'argent on va en
parler maintenant ça va non mais c'est
vrai que vous ressentez un peu toutes
les critiques comme des agressions non
non mais je pense que moi j'ai eu mon
on m'a critiqué on a raison une
franchise si je suis pas bon c'est pas
c'est pas un problème mais je pense
qu'il ya des critiques sont pas fondés à
demander ça me ça m'énerve c'est vrai
quand on m'a qualifié de personnes
antenne de qui elle qui avait la grosse
grosse tête on a dit c'est vrai la
grossesse est vrai c'est vrai alors que
quand on vous voir mes chevilles mais
mais non mais si le problème bon le
problème il est là mais c'est pas trés
c'est pas très grave en soi mais c'est
vrai que non un manque de reconnaissance
non dites moi alors marseille
relégables en d2 la non bah non quand
même pas loin mais non pas loin non mais
bon on est en période difficile c'est
clair mais je pense que je pense que ça
va aller beaucoup mieux
ouais j'espère et si marseille
descendent des deux vous rester ou non
moi je pense rester mais j'ai encore
deux ans de contrat je pense qu'il ya
j'ai toujours respecté j'ai fait
toujours fait des longs contrats et j'ai
toujours respecté le club auquel j'ai
appartenu et métaux sont je suis à agir
et à 99% sûr que l'om ne descendra pas
ce thème un mois si je vais jouer à
marseille
oui c'est pour moi un honneur et c'est
écrit sur ses pas sur un effet lemercier
à marseille n'y a pas eu et on peut dire
qu'il y en ait fait le buzz ce lieu
magnifique
non mais
non mais ça c'est vrai que ce nom ça
s'est très bien passé
et vous n'avez pas de terrasse à
marseille tu m'as fait retentir une
terrasse à marseille mais je peux te
dire un truc c'est que en angleterre il
avait une belle maison 1 300 m il a une
maison de 300 mètres carrés
piscines piscine intérieure trois étages
ouais non mais c'était bien c'était mais
c'est un investissement moi je loge la
revendre donc voila quoi mais c'était
juste parce que ponctuelle bouna si vous
l'aviez acheté en plus cette barre ouais
je l'avais acheté à une époque où ou la
livre montait où tout le monde m'a dit
mais tu es fou d'acheter et en fin de
compte j'espère bien la vente quoi
et plutôt que de faire un loyer à loyers
sur exorbitants j'essaye déjà de vendre
la maison avec le 11 septembre c'est pas
évident et ça s'est passé en angleterre
ça stagne est un petit peu mais c'est
sûr que les princes saoudiens en
angleterre by the way victoria beckham
qui va venir tout à l'heure peut-être
que polluantes
voilà dix plus qu'à une terrasse avec un
petit
en scène en soirée alors je vous ai fait
un reportage sur cette maison ne savait
pas été très bons pour votre image
surtout en france avaient été très
mauvais mais il faut savoir reconnaître
ses erreurs c'était une grosse erreur
j'ai suivi un petit peu l'élan 98 tout
on a des champions du brando il fallait
tout savoir sur eux c'est vrai j'étais
sympa j'ai ouvert ma maison une femme
des enfants une maison est nécessaire
c'est vraiment là et à la sortie ça m'a
sorti ça vient de tomber sur le nez
parce que bon c'est clair qu'il y avait
il y avait la maison était grande
il y avait une piscine intérieure donc
c'est vrai que ça gênait richard ans il
fallait que je sois toujours pauvres
mais c'est même lui dit quand même
l'argent me fait flipper à mort pas
question de me retrouver plus mais comme
giresse non mais c'est à dire que c'est
pas le cas j'irai s'est fait plumer
parce qu'il y avait quelqu'un qui lui a
piqué son argent ah ouais je connais pas
les tenants et tous les tenants et les
aboutissants de son histoire mais je
sais que ça a été un gros problème pour
lui
j'espère juste faire attention problème
c'est que on est obligé quand même de
faire confiance à des financiers moi
j'en ai trouvé un qui me semble très
très bien et et à qui je fais
pratiquement totale confiance mais
il faut toujours faire attention puisque
d'autres carrières est très courte et
que si déjà 34 ans vous parlez d'arrêter
oui c'est sûr que c'est oui je vais
arrêter parce que je veux pas être
ridicule sur un terrain qu'on ne dise
pas que d'après les données des biens
immobiliers non non non je vais je vais
commencer à prendre des cours de théâtre
parce que ça me plaît des cours de flûte
et à l'argent donc l'argent ouais
financièrement devait de trouver un bon
financier en qui la totale confiance
nous savons quoi il investit votre
argent ouais dans des valeurs monétaires
on a beaucoup investi dans l'immobilier
aussi parce qu'on y croit j'ai quelques
appartements en france pour en locatif
donc c'est sympa owen locatif avec les
cyclones et attends mon blog c'est un
mec qui l'a pas les mariés en même temps
mais la mecque mais c'est parce que moi
je pensais le marié avec ophélie et je
me disais tous les deux et sont très mal
et si ça fait des années ils sont connus
à l'école et j'ai très belles dents
ouais c'est gentil s'attend comme le dit
c'est vrai c'est vrai sinon merci
beaucoup à paul théâtre vous êtes quand
même très près de très près du pognon je
vous avais dit oh un journaliste du
nouvel observateur vous remarquez que je
ne vous fais pas payer l'interview deux
heures d'interviews ces deux heures de
mon temps ouais ben c'est pas sûr que
j'ai eu une culture un petit peu
anglaise pendant cinq ans et que quand
je
donner une interview à une télévision à
un temps de télévision en angleterre
j'ai été payé à tirer on vous êtes payé
les gens qui sont autour ils sont payés
et nous ne sommes pas payés rien du tout
les armes que vous voulez rouler pour la
meilleure émission c'était un deuxième
sac un sac sur sa terrasse en terrasse
voilà y'a pas de problème mais bon voilà
on fait passer pour un homme d'argent
non je vais dire je veux dire la vérité
en fait vous avez ras mais vous en avez
souffert de l'argent parce que quand
vous avez été viré de toulon qui était
votre premier club que tu arrivé à meaux
en 87 en d3 et à l'époque vous gagner
500 francs par mois
et voilà de quoi je fais quatre pots de
moutarde et y disposer de 350 francs par
semaine mais pour faire à manger et le
coca était réservée aux amis bah ouais
bah quand on n'a pas d'argent il faut
faire attention aux objets j'en vois pas
voilà de l'eau du robinet cette rapidité
de l'audio et où les faire attention
c'est pour ça que je fais attention à
l'argent on parle beaucoup d'argent mais
je fais attention à l'argent parce que
j'en ai manqué et que j'ai galéré que
j'ai envie que mes enfants ne cessera
cet agent cet argent servira pour les
études des enfants et et moi si je finis
avec x 0 franc la fin de ma vie j'en à
foot voilà vous êtes intéressé par
l'argent parce que vous savez exactement
ça lui il va leur laisser plein
appartement c'est sûr pendant vingt ans
à bien il est très malin le peuple quand
vous avez quitté mauvais chercher du
boulot dans un club
j'ai fait une petite cassette une petite
cassette vhs avec vos meilleurs au
meilleur moment vos meilleurs buts et
cetera mais vous avez envoyé à laval et
à auxerre et c'est laval qui a répondu
le premier livre a été un peu plus lent
sur le coup et c'est très bien on
voulait vraiment quoi les gens voulaient
non bien sûr ce n'était pas courant je
les fais parce que je voyais pas la fin
du tunnel et que j'étais en troisième
division
et que mon envie c'est de valeur
professionnelle voilà alors après il ya
eu strasbourg vous a laissé faire mes
problèmes avec grèce la lanterne suisse
trois ans de calvaire avec lui quand
même ouais trois ans de calvaire
motivant le maquis vous disais tu es un
connard tu gagneras jamais rien ouais
c'est ce qui m'a dit un jour je l'en
remercie
il sait motiver c'est bien mais je l'en
remercie parce qu'en fin de compte il va
donner envie de lui montrer qu'il avait
tort âge
ouais après chelsea dans quelle équipe
de france a' autre celle ci quand même
là ça allait un million de francs par
mois ça va et on revient sur l'argent
dans l'équipe de france il ya eu ce
problème avec laurent blanc quoi il n'y
a pas eu de problème si vous avez
répondu que vous êtes là pour vous
expliquer comme vous et disputé la
finale contre le brésil à la place de
laurent blanc vous avez dit désolé pour
lolo mais ma joie est supérieur à ma
peine pour lui je réponds mensonge sur
mensonge c'est à dire que j'ai fait une
conférence de presse la veille de la
finale de la coupe du monde et on m'a
parlé pendant trois quarts d'heure de la
suspension de laurent blanc je trouvais
ça dégueulasse qu'ils soient soient pas
qu'il n'ait pas joué la finale parce
qu'il mérite et de la jouer parce qu'il
m'a été surtout pas d'être expulsé
et c'est tout donc pendant au bout de
trois quarts d'heure les journalistes
ont donné si vous êtes fait quand même
content content j'ai joué en finale de
coupe du monde j'avais quand même pas
pleurer les rosiers était remplaçant
pendant longtemps mais non mais non pas
lui il aurait fallu un mandat exclusif
non je peux pas jouer ouais pas céder
que je peux pas le faire je peux pas
donc en or il aurait joué à dix on
aurait mis quelqu'un qui était pas à sa
place
non donc j'ai décidé de jouer et c'est
vrai que j'ai passé quatre jours à 3
parce que je pourrai pas lui mais la
télévision je peux pas lire les journaux
parce que c'était comment allait faire
sans lolo auquel cas vous avez jamais
dit ça non jamais content c'était
horrible on a dit qu'on m'a dit à la fin
du match et à bilic celui qui a fait
expulser laurent blanc qui était monté
sur le dernier corner et leurs beats
siffle la fin et je me retourne il est
là il tombe dans mes bras et regarder
vous étiez d'accord
ouais que celui que j'avais payé pour
faire expulser laurent blanc qu'on va
arrêter c'est vraiment dégueulasse
je pensais beaucoup étaient pour arrêter
le mieux arrêter
alors quand vous avez eu des hauts et
comme vous avez eu des barres en fer
interview à peine d'anne frank leboeuf
on accouche dans le qinghai
on
ce que vous préférez en vous qui joue
mon coeur votre bon coeur votre coeur je
pense que j'ai grand coeur ouais ouais
ce que vous haïssez en vous c'est
difficile à dire
comme si vous répondez pas c'est le
voisin qui répond c'est le principe créé
doit hisser en we say die je suis trop
bavard ouais obama a aussi comme on
vient de le voir parce que vous préférez
dans le foot
non non parce que moi j'essaie d'éviter
que les gens marque début la
collectivité la collectivité c'est ce
qu'on appelait le collectif du corps
d'aimé jacquet voilà ouais faut pas être
personnel non j'aime bien la vie enfin
la vie à un groupe
les échanges et le fait de se le fait de
se bouger pour un copain le soir à
clairefontaine la chaude ambiance tout
ça ça vous plaît ouais vous devriez
venir j'ai 40 et la chaude ambiance
pattes avant pas du tout ce que vous
détestez dans le foot
la mauvaise presse ouais ouais les gens
qui font exprès de vous faire du mal
ils sont prêts à cela j'ai lu à la
télévision après une coupe du monde qui
le font jamais et qui sont capables de
vous dire que s'il n'avait pas fait ça
vous n'aurez pas gagné la coupe du monde
1 le mec de l'équipe exact bureau jérôme
bureau et m'a dit sans nom a bâti son
nom qui nous fait chier que poudre aux
yeux bleu gris première fois que j'ai eu
ma femme quand je suis rentré dans le
train c'est vrai ça s'est passé comment
raconter nous parce que ça peut à daloa
me bats je prenais le train l'été dans
ce train et javier doua ou louer tout
savoir
oui j'allais de je prenais le train à
bandol quitte à bandol et chalets sur
toulon sur toulon et ma femme était déjà
dans le train était monté sur l'a77
jolie demoiselle était rentré dans le
tralala la station d'avant et je l' ai
vu je suis pas fâché horaire mais je me
suis mis derrière moi et je voyais que
sa copine a parlé de moi donc j'ai dit
il y a il ya quelque chose de possible
donc c'est vrai que j'ai marché gelé
suivi tout le temps je pour savoir où
aller où elle allait oui je savais je
vais parler une copine à elle est vue
donc voilà qu'on a essayé de se voir
mais on s'est perdus de vue pendant deux
mois et retrouver après encore dans dans
le train puisque je prenais le train
tous les jours elle aussi c'est qu'on a
commencé à se parler de quoi et après
donc voilà donc après on s'est parlé ça
a duré deux mois trois mois
par les jeux etc ont pu assez vite après
j'ai conclu
non nous trois mois j'ai là j'ai réussi
à l'embrasser puis bout voilà pour
conclure il a fallu encore attendre
c'est bon d'accord elle était jeune
pâtissier pour conclure non quand même
pas quand même quand même pas mais
toujours avec cette fin d'année ça fait
ça à faire 17 ans c'est beau ouais ça
c'est
c'est pas si difficile quand même non
non c'est pas difficile au contraire
s'est passé c'est facile parce que elle
est facile et parce que le pire moment
de votre vie le pire moment de ma vie je
le vis en ce moment avec les problèmes
de mon père je le deviens en ce moment
parce que c'est c'est tous les jours
c'est pas de pas de répit et puis une
amélioration mini mini mine tous les
jours quand c'est pas au contraire une
descente aux enfers et en ce moment
c'est très difficile way se faisait de
plus sexy en vous c'est pas faut
demander aux à valérie oui pour vous
filer les yeux front et sexy je vous ai
de moins sexy money mon souci aussi fin
et c'est que s'ils sont nés francs ouais
ouais un peu fracassants
oui oui c'est bien mais pourquoi et des
grands très grands
ben alors voilà je compte aussi les 20
grands n'est pas bon j'y vais ça fait
plaisir mais c'est vrai
attention ce que vous préférez dans le
sexe tous avaient tous tour on sait que
c'est vrai c'est bon quand c'est bien
fait c'est bon c'est bon
ah ouais ah ouais non vous êtes une
bonne affaire voix à moi j'ai passé une
bonne affaire me faudrait demander à mon
épouse mes
ce qui vous dégoûte dans le sexe on ne
souffle pas photo philippe qui vous
dégoûte mais c'est tout je comprends que
ça fait 17 ans et avec un chèque des
poneys
et maintenant la chopine la chambre
si jean yanne
comment ça va il ya un moment on
croirait qu'on du bord la dernière fois
vous êtes venu il ya quoi il ya un nom
pour un livre déjà un
on a tout raconté des gens pas
recommencer voorhees face ça tout de
suite pour me [__] la paix non on
arrive le fait on voulait le faire oui
toute façon la dernière fois vous êtes
venu on va parler de votre vie la drogue
la prostitution
oui puis on avait parlé de votre
aventure avec va pas recommencer on va
passer à la promo directement vous êtes
prêts pour faire des petites mains là
j'ai vu que j'étais bien
il faut pas dire ah non c'est pas bien
mais il faut rentrer dans le truc c'est
l'état oui pourquoi
pour faire la promotion d'un livre aux
éditions du cherche midi que j'ai écris
moi même et qui s'appelle
je suis un être exquis alors c'est un
recueil de pensées d'articles de texte
extraordinaire comme tout ce que vous
faites toute façon depuis que depuis que
je vous connais le ton est donné dès la
page de garde vous dites je n'ai plus
aucun propos dignes de confiance
j'ai tout dit j'ai menti à tout le monde
je ne sais plus ce que j'ai signes qui
voilà comme ça au moins c'est clair non
c'est pas la peine de dire rage j'ai
plongé dans mes souvenirs
ce que je dis est sincère j'aime j'aime
ça je veux faire profiter le monde de
mes découvertes et de ma connaissance
jeudi je m'en fous c'est pour tout ça
vous va bien de jacou de caton animal
c'est aux éditions du cherche midi
voilà et c'est bientôt noël je venais
des cas vous allez lire les maximes que
j'ai noté vous êtes prêts oui page 14
l'amour est aveugle la preuve en le
faisant il ya des gens qui braille
page 20 l'argent ne fait pas le bonheur
des convoyeurs de fonds va t on
cambronne ne mâchait pas ses mots
heureusement pour lui
24 les bonnes femmes sont toutes les
mêmes elles nous insultent parce qu'on
arrive en terre et elle nous demande
pourquoi on n'a pas appelé pour ne pas
se faire insulter deux fois toi 28 c'est
quand on commence à payer des pensions
alimentaires qu'on se rend compte à quel
point moi ça passe vite mais continue un
peu ça va ils ont il faut leur laisser
un peu ses pertes et lâche et plus après
non ce n'est pas ça mais c'est parce que
toujours un peu bébête quand quand on
est quand on raconte soi même les trucs
87 87
je serais à la place des agriculteurs
qui dépose du fumier devant les mcdo
je me méfierais parce que les gérants
vont finir par croire qu'il s'agit d'une
livre
donc on va faire une petite interview a
redit view vous êtes près sûr
pour la gauche par jean galle
vous pensez à quoi là en ce moment à
rien je suis si je pense que j'ai je me
suis précipité sur un petit bout de pain
avec du jambon de bayonne en arrivant et
là il vous reste sur l'estomac
non je suis mais j'aurais dû avoir la
patience d'attendre pour la guinée voilà
bah voilà quand vous regardez le matin
dans la glace vous dites quoi
je regarde si je suis raccords pour la
barbe ah ah oui parce que si je peux
gagner encore un jour ça va mais si
c'est en tournage j'ai dit bon ça rien
lâché 2 mm de plus alors j'ai du boulot
non c'est très difficile où un boulot
non mais je veux dire c'est aussi dur
que quand vous étiez petit vous auriez
aimé ressembler à qui un adulte
n'importe quel adulte ce qui arrive est
votre plus belle histoire d'amour
je n'aime que des belles histoires
d'amour je n'ai pas eu une plus belle
qu'il autres mais beaucoup hein
un paquet aïe je regardais en
préparation mais c'est énorme
non mais c'est vrai inquiet des défis
sublimons plus sublime pourquoi parce
que je suis honnête rixe qui a montré le
bout calquant modique somme est ce que
c'est la vérité
alors quand on vous demande des
autographes vous écrivez quoi ah bah ça
dépend en principe j'écris toujours dans
la rue ou ou sur un livre blanc dans la
rue au nom dans la rue j'écris bons
souvenirs dans les livres jeux
j'ai pas besoin de faire grand-chose jeu
mais c'est bien vrai et ça oui c'est au
titre
quand avez vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois je pleure uniquement à l'occasion
des morts ouais t'es qui là bas tout le
monde est mort un jeune le problème
c'est que si vous voulez j'ai fait une
émission récemment avec un type qui m'a
mis deux ans une affiche de tout le
monde il est beau tout le monde il est
gentil cayzelle prolifique j'avais
réalisé et qui me dire il ya longtemps
les a vu cette affiche
et oui bien sûr et en temps et alors
qu'est ce que ça vous fait de la revoir
alors j'ai vu quand jean pierre rassam
et jean yanne présente jean pierre
rassam
exit way un scénario déjà six régions
yann gérard cyr ainsi que michel magne
plus de michel magne avec bernard blier
avec des mots plus que moi vous
changeriez qu en vous si vous aviez une
baguette magique
mon ventre j'aurai des abdominaux comme
des plaques de chocolat je rêve de ça
ouais ne me balader sur les plages et
que du coup ça se précipite sur moi pour
avoir mal
vous trouvez comment ben ouais douillet
c'est sympa robillard un canton n'est
pas lui ça va ouais non c'est vrai il ya
un avantage considérable à elles peuvent
alors ça c'est un truc que j'ai pu
observer cent mille fois quand on est
poilu et barbu on peut être gros et
habillés avec des choses rigolotes oui
c'est vrai 1
vous pourrez frimer un carlos carlos
éminemment sympathique jean pierre coffe
il voit là il est gros bon ben c'est
bien il à la barbe
il peut se mettre des tee-shirts de
couleur des chemises hawaïennes bon vous
voyez pas je suis pas comme ça non
quel péché qui vous tente le plus gênant
c'est l'avarice parce que l'avarice
c'est le peut c'est le seul péché qu'on
peut avoir même quand on est pauvre jean
yanne que diriez-vous de plus négatif
sur vos de plus négatif sur moi est
vraiment pour vous auto iv c'est pour
mosley pour nous cela est maintenant
tout le monde est une fois pour toutes
j'aurais vraiment pu faire mieux ouais
ça c'est vrai moi je voulais dit
j'aurais vraiment pu faire mieux si je
n'avais pas été aussi flemmards mais en
fait même pas flemmard je n'ai jamais
jamais été un battant et donc d'accès
difficile je m'arrête
ouais donc je n'aurais jamais pu être
sportif ou franck leboeuf
moi j'aurais donné un coup de pied
montréal mec m'a effleuré le genou on en
mange pas parfait et le football de ces
jeux c'est exact vous avez dit pendant
longtemps j'ai un gros défaut par
rapport au sport je l'est aussi par
rapport à ce spectacle je reconnais pas
les gens alors évidemment j'ai une
admiration sans borne pour les mecs qui
disent machin qui passe à machin qu'il
fasse un match entier
vous adorez les volants mais oui parce
que moi je vois un type qui pousse un
ballon qui donne un autre mais qui donne
un coup de ballon et puis le stade se
lève
j'ai même pas vu car cette date et
comment ils font il met des numéros sur
le dos des gens à bin ouais il faut
associer le papier m même les noms mal
an der et non un sujet qui avez vous le
plus envie d'épater monfils vous feriez
quoi s'il vous restait 24 heures à vivre
ce qui est bien c'est qu'en ce moment
cette question c'est vraiment gay votre
avis sur le sait vraiment si j'avais 24
heures je ferai pas grand chose parce
qu'en 24 heures je n'aurai pas le temps
de faire tout ce que j'ai à faire et que
j'aurais déjà dû faire ouais mais je
crois que j'essaierai d'être avec eux
les gens qui m'aiment bien mais pas trop
pour pas leur faire de chagrin ouais je
me ferai un petit plateau télé
ouais je le ferai un petit whisky et je
mettrai la téloche
voilà voilà c'est terrible c'est
terrible alors parce que vous allez pas
prier dans une église dans un entrevue
je vais vous dire très franchement à 24
ans ça sert plus à rien salut tu te fous
de ma gueule tu vas pas te repartir
maintenant 24 heures c'est vrai que dieu
et comme vous allez beaucoup plus
miséricordieux
non pas du tout ce que dieu m'a fait à
son image bâtissez bien se réjouissait
vous y serez surpris le surnom qu'on
vous donne que vous haïssez non non moi
je ne me dérange pas les surnoms de
toute façon les on évolue on les oublie
lens qui me ce qui me ce qui met ce qui
m'énerve c'est quand les gens allant
moins - maintenant c'est quand les gens
ne me tutoie dans la rue mais il me
bouscule leurs jalons et ça va et
pourtant il ya tellement de gens qui ont
un nom mais ça dépend qui aussi je vois
une fille longiligne les bas à gainer
donilon celui sétois s'approche de moi
et qui me dit dans un souffle
de quelle question aimeriez vous avoir
la réponse
la survie enfin le snj a pas de mort si
c'est après l'aller 1
il ya quand on est amoureux ce qui nous
énerve le plus en vo jeu pas le courage
de de dire non à des allées chose qui
m'emmerde à mourir un tube on allait le
faire est-ce que vous énerve le plus
chez moi
non pourquoi non non j'ai pas d'argent
on peut tout se dire ce soir non non je
sais bien nommé - non pourquoi vous
m'énervez pendre c'est vrai oh non c'est
sûr oui bon je serais pas venu gens
c'est un nombre même un peu oui non mais
j'ai même une certaine passion par
filise rien que parce que j'aime bien
que je sois toujours en noir
cette plaie ça que je suis là tu avais
marre
ça va être moins gai parce qu'on passe
un e-mail consacré à notre ami michaël
blanc qui s'est fait choper à bali avec
de la drogue
ils ont fermé et mais qu'il a pris
perpet pour 1 kg 8 de shit dans une
bouteille de plongée
non si on peut plus se mettre ko sur mon
état il a plongé alors où va t'on
s'améliorait mais un mec était
pratiquement shit mois qui passaient les
bouteilles de plongée en fraude a way
attendu valve hot chip de 12 kg il
mettait une bouteille et pagesjaunes en
plus alors je voudrais remercier les
donateurs au nom de la famille de
michael blanc pour le moment la famille
a reçu 20 mille francs
alors j'ai trouvé un truc c'est que si
chacun est à peu près 2 3 millions de
gens qui regardent cette émission si
chacun donne un franc le type est sauvé
oui moi je connais bien les sauver il
est sauvé à ce qu'il faut bakchich et
pour le soir oui bien sûr c'est sur moi
j'y retourne à bali donc avant la loi il
à la prison de denpasar non mais c'est
vrai c'est là la foufoune on pense
qu'avec 1 millions 7,1 millions 8 voire
2 millions on peut le sortir de là donc
si chacun donne en france beaucoup fait
un chèque d'un franc
l'adresse s'écrit en bas de l'écran
pendant que je le dis et l'ordre ses
soutiens michaël blanc voilà jorian je
suis jamais fixé aux éditions du cherche
midi
des pensées des articles
formidable bouquin que tout le monde
doit avoir dans son avion j'accueille
maintenant victoria beckham
des qualités liberia lesquin évidemment
ayant vécu en angleterre alors victoria
d'abord je vais voir si la traductrice
et la belinda belinda il a comme
d'habitude prête travail pour linda je
voulais vous dire merci un pour l'autre
soir c'était vraiment sympa
la tarte tatin la bonne tarte aux pommes
fait maison dans la petite gâterie après
l'émission
oui c'est bien ce dont je parle des
passants l'ont bien savoir corti était
ravie aussi jouer mais c'est ça le monde
du virtuel on reste bien du tout baffie
éboulis ont regretté de pas être là je
vais te le dire voilà donc victoria
bonsoir ça s'est traduit chitwan 106 ok
ça veut dire bonsoir je sais mais si
c'est belinda des fois là un peu du mal
à traduire un peu mais là ya pas trop
besoin de cela is ok ça doit être
parfait parce qu'en france est en fait
trop visible mais l'une d'elle mais je
peux faire bed-in belinda est-ce que je
peux prendre ta place au boss que thiery
10 1 c'est le chef ben moi si tu es
capable de le faire c'est très difficile
avant six à des trucs trop compliqué non
mais c'est une première question ça
al'air belinda c'est pareil alors
victoria bon choix
je suis en cercle si l'hôpital qui
concerne la mécanique des fluides
bien sûr
même si je me suis permise et là bas
alors victoria beckham quand vous
faisiez partie des spice girls sont vous
appelez poche parce que vous étiez un
petit peu la snob du groupe
la spécialiste des vêtements de marque
c'est ça il ya fait il ya beaucoup de
gens que j'étais la personne qui avait
le look un peu le plus noble avec eux
ses hauts talons mais j'ai fait beaucoup
plus de choses j'ai créé un album est
donc je suis très occupé ouais mais
évidemment je vais au shopping mais pas
autant qu'on le dit ouais alors votre
nom de course en course annoncé les
chevaux mais inactive en course donc
votre concours votre nom de translate h
is she is bad
alors qu'est-ce que je fais là rien du
tout you just under my way votre nom de
famille c'est adams fait particulier du
ministère en cinq ans
bon on va de bonne famille c'est adam
fait partie de la famille adams et vous
êtes marié avec une star du football
anglais qui s'appelle david beckham très
connue c'est une énorme star david
beckham le boeuf non salées way un salut
vous l'aimez pas je ne connais pas donc
j'en parle pas mais je vais jouer contre
lui je vais continuer plusieurs fort et
là on avait mis un coup de genou
non on a eu quelques anicroches mais ça
va ce qu'il faut savoir c'est comme en
angleterre
victoria beckham david beckham son
statut d'idole vous êtes un peu comme
diana
la presse anglaise aujourd'hui quand
elle met soi vous soit votre mari soit
les deux en couverture augmente ses
tirages de 20%
effectivement j'ai diddy était très snob
et ai été vraiment populaire mais en
fait c'est parce que mon mari a beaucoup
de succès avec le football et je faisais
partie un espace vierge et c'est un
groupe extrêmement important évidemment
l'intérêt se magnifie avec ce couple qui
se forme très bien bien pour magnifique
pas mal comme un ce magnifique merci
valérie avant des droits de la femme de
david beckham vous avez été connu pour
ça
m
il ya m
ok
m
c'est nous
celle là on va la voir en magnétos
magnéto serge
et en fait
m
non
là
risers vivier encore dit
l'espagne vient 40 millions d'albums
vendus dans le monde
ça laisse quand même
et aujourd'hui le premier cd solo en ce
moment qu'une eau à owendo et en france
avaient commencé enfin je vais
t'apprendre mamans voilées attention tu
mets tes petites mains comme ça
attention
elle le fait bien
moi je trouve qu elle le fait très bien
bravo je comprends que vous soyez devenu
la star que vous êtes alors donc
maintenant il ya un nouveau disque dans
un single est tiré et c'est ça
tél
m
g
non
ça s'appelle note search and in some
girls
ce qui veut dire jean racine de chercher
ça ouais shopping
je ne sais pas si innocente que ça
chante victoria beckham vous dites sur
cet album je ne suis pas posh spice et
des spice girls c'est pas posh et becks
votre mari c'est victoria beckham pour
la première fois c'est à dire que vous
assumez votre personnalité ce que vous
êtes vraiment en fait je suis très fier
de tout ce que nous avons pu faire en
tant que groupe
les médias sont très intéressants parce
post bac
je rends fait tout ce que je voudrais
c'est avec ma propre identité c'est pour
ça que je veux être victoria beckham je
veux qu'on prenne un peu c'est très bon
et qu'on disait voilà c'est moi et je
suis très fier de cet album que je j'ai
fait je veux être un individu à part
entière voilà et voilà comprenez ça
c'est un truc vous auriez dû comprendre
plutôt janssen jeune individu à partir
et je me suis habitué à vouloir me mêler
à la foule à former des groupes et des
choses pas ça n'aurait dû être
indépendant voilà comme tout le monde
mais voilà alors on va regarder un
oiseau de faire des trucs comme une girl
et le costume avaient pas été ridicules
matin m
7 heures
victoria beckham ça premier album
s'envoler sur la brune et la blonde qui
sommeille en nous voilà c'est à dire que
healy attendant au fait l'ail et moi
nous sommes à la fin la blonde et la
brune hockey lah et victoria c'est la
même chose voilà exactement la blonde et
là je vous préfère en brune
est ce que vous avez eu des déceptions
amoureuses avec des copines vous mais
non pas amoureuse amical ouais c'est ça
parce que le victoria une grave
déception on peut le dire avec geri
halliwell oula considériez comme votre
meilleur ami votre blonde et c'était
giri qui a décidé de se séparer du les
médias aiment en fait créé des problèmes
qui n'existent pas réparé en angleterre
ils préfèrent ils donné l'histoire
négative que le scénario positif c'est
un problème à la fois dire quand même
déjà à l'école j'étais pas la copine de
tout le monde s'est déjà plaint de
problèmes à l'école vous dites on ne
considérait à l'école comme une
extraterrestre
j'avais de gros problèmes d'acné c'est
vrai quand vous appelez sticky vie qui
est oui dit j'arrivais tous les matins
en rolls avec mon père et c'est vrai que
ça crée des problèmes
en fait une bonne élève
je voulais avoir une bonne performance
sur travaillé très dur que ce soit pour
la danse le chant
oui et c'était ce qu'il y avait à faire
à l'école et je pense que les enfants
d'accepter rabat j'étais ambitieuse
comme votre père d'ailleurs quelqu'un
qui vient de la middle class et qui à
force de travail à caen oui oui à force
de travail il a monté une entreprise
d'électricité le père de victoria
il a acheté une rolls et a pris date
leur ôter la vie de sa fille absolument
et à 8 ans
à l'âge de 8 ans vous avez war fame
d'alan parker et c'est un coup énorme
dans votre vie vous décidé à ce moment
là de vous lancer dans la carrière du
spectacle je suis belinda excusez moi je
suis là mais le moment je suis tellement
compliqué je parie que vous allez voir
faits et a finalement été à mon avis m'a
prouvé que si on travaille vraiment dur
et qu'on veut quelque chose on peut y
arriver et j'ai beaucoup travaillé comme
un père et je suis allé voir fait mais
j'ai vu ses jambes sur la scène du ciné
mais c'est moi et je dois y être et
c'est la même chose avec david quand il
regardait le football on se disait même
si je travaille très dur j'y arriverai
aussi rien n'est perdu si jean rien ne
veut des plaquettes de chocolat il a
peur mais bien entendu il suffit de
regarder franck voilà un nom mais ce qui
est terrible avec victoria sait qu'un
jour elle va voir mentionné de de cliff
richard bien sûr elle va cliff richard
wiblet elle dit un jour je serai là et
bien avec les spice girls
elle s'y retrouver c'est vrai c'est ça
qui est merveilleux enfants
on se moque de faire ce qu'il faut faire
ou pas faire j'ai simplement vu cet
homme sur la scène me suis dit ah je
veux faire la même chose ce serait la
même chose vous l'avez fait maintenant
voilà mais vous l'avez fait et je dois
continuer à travailler très dur parce
qu'il ya des gens un coup de gens qui
ont des préjugés comme vous l'avez dit
étant donné que j'étais la porsche la
snobe on pensait que je ne faisais que
des courses et que je portais des hauts
talons c'est pas des cons c'est pas un
cheval on fait un peu de shopping donc
aller au shopping vous décidez aux
cheveux courts en or on peut aller au
shopi voilà et on peut aussi aller au
choix là mais quand vont tracer de
manière dont on peut faire du chopper on
va mais c'est en fait sérieux
songes organiser les jeux par quelques
batteries dont je dis on dit pas on va
au shopping dit on va au cabinet dit je
fais en cabinet d'un fin au cabinet
c'est vrai et alors donc un jour je
continue de l'histoire de poche un jour
vous allez sur un stade de foot et vous
voyez david beckham et vous dites je le
veux aw oui c'est à peu près ça et quand
vous l'avez séduit qui ne vendent pas et
fait je gardais du mauvais côté et au
travers de tout le match dont tu
regardais pas les bonnes équipes mais
quand je les ai vus après je me suis dit
c'est lui que je veux et comment vous
avez fait pour le gagner avec mon chat à
votre choix je crois vraiment la voir et
on s'entend aussi entendu très bien
depuis tout début c'est que faisait que
commencer
et c'était quelque chose à part plus bas
niveau que ça ne l'est mais vous verrez
donner confiance en lui et vous a donné
confiance en vous ils n'étaient pas en
train à bandol pas du tout mais pourquoi
ça marche on va regarder à côté de son
mari
victoria beckham en angleterre vous êtes
comme un couple royal avec deux médias
sa voix
il est prête à devenir son esclave
sexuelle would you be comme sex love toi
ça y est
vous seriez prête à devenir son esclave
sexuelle would you be comme sex love toi
et vous mais peut-être il est lui-même
mon esclave c'est ça l'histoire et pas
franck moi je suis l'esclave sexuelle de
ma femme quand elle veut voilà solo
mélinda je vais te salue et moi de même
bon comme d'habitude un à la prochaine
non allez en aller dont victoria will
tell you good bye
on va vous dire en forme maintenant
victoria très bien bye bye
see you soon
qu'est ce qu'on pense je fais quelques
stars d'angleterre n'en font tous pour
un ah ouais non mais les contrats où ils
ont des contrats personnels avec les
tabloïds ccc des gens très c'est vrai
qu'il se montre énormément et que dès
qu'ils font un pas c'est vrai qu'ils
sont épiés mais bon il aime bien et ça
devient tout ça ou pas la semaine
dernière il est apparu lui avec des
boucles d'oreilles en argent la montre
en diamants le montre entièrement la
bague en diamant voilà dix ans il aime
bien ce à quoi donc
bon ils peuvent pas hyper intéressant ce
qu'on club est ce vrai maintenant nous
recevons
messieurs le monde chapeau
voici le directeur de la rédaction du
monde edwy plenel
elle lui plaît tellement soir soit vous
connaissez tous le monde est à peu près
quand vous êtes directeur de la
rédaction du journal le monde c'est pas
de la rigolade à mon pote 1
j'ai fait un mayen depuis tout à l'heure
de jeu disait le bêtise avant il à andy
rédacteur en chef du monde ma oui
surtout que bras
bien nous publié chez stock un livre qui
s'appelle secret de jeunesse et qui
vient d'avoir le prix médicis de l'essai
vous savez comment on fait des je sais
je sais et oui ça va être votre tour
alonso wes jaunies des mois je suis
faire ça avait fait ça c'est bien aussi
c'est mieux oui c'est ça fait ça aussi
si vous voulez à nancy 1 2 3 c'est là du
logement discuter avant avec jean marie
colombani bernard henri lévy pour savoir
s'il fallait faire ça ou ça pousse à
bout ça ou s'amuser base acquis mais
c'est bien ça c'est pas mal aussi ça oui
non mais le livre ça raconte une
histoire où c'est ça assez clair alors
on va parler de vous de votre livre de
votre vie attention vous êtes prêts
l'orge est né en 1952 la nantes votre
père alain était inspecteur d'académie
et professeur d'histoire et vous avez
passé votre enfance en algérie et il
faut attendre la fin de votre bouquin
pour que vous en donniez l'explication
pourquoi vous êtes retrouvé en algérie
parce que mon père et a quitté la france
parce qu'il n'aimait pas le gaullisme
d'état réalisme un peu policiers pas le
gaullisme de résistance là on veut faire
un coup de chapeau celui qui y avait les
humoristes
il y avait un amour de josiane pour
respirer un petit peu à l'époque
ouais le dire comme ça ouais donc il a
il est parti oui enfin il faut dire
aussi qu'il ya des interviews dans un
journal algérien
oui il a dit que l'intervention
colonialiste il était il était contre le
fait que la france où priment d'autres
peuples peut le dire aussi simplement
que ça alors votre père s'est donc
retrouvé fonctionnaire algérien donc
pour y travailler pour le régime
algérien et c'est effectivement le sol
homme de gauche avoir choisi l'exil sous
le gaullisme d'état n'y a pas eu
d'autres exemples dans ma connaissance
je pense pas enfin il a fait ça tout
seul un ouais il entraîner personnes
ouais vous c'est une dette d'enfants
sont à lire comme ça au passé votre
enfance et votre adolescence en algérie
avec un père effectivement donc
fonctionnaires l'état algérien se dire
assez mal payés et puis d'une façon
assez aléatoire alors vous arrivé à
paris en soixante dix ans pète fait
sciences po puis du journalisme à rouge
qui le journal de la ligue communiste
révolutionnaire de 76 à 78
ensuite le matin de paris et puis après
vous rentrez au monde et vous y être
depuis 1981 un bail et vous vous y
signalé par deux fameuses enquêtes que
tout le monde connaît la sphère du
rainbow warrior soon est sa musique
douce et turin thuringe voilà ah oui le
canada du rainbow warrior dans ce cas
l'entrée de lens c'est le
une histoire qui a été complètement
survolée par monsieur fabius way qui a
fait plusieurs apparitions à la
télévision et qui à chaque fois mais une
veste de couleur
ouais c'est bien il à nivet il est venu
par les époux tu ranges avec une petite
veste bleu bleu ciel puis après rose
bonbon
après fuchsia et tout et il essayait de
noyer le poisson alors qu'on sert
exhorté les poissons avait été noyée
depuis longtemps voilà certains de jute
qui était parti pour faire sauter un
bateau un truc qui l'auront petty dans
les lois c'est grâce à vous qu'on a su
la vérité
ensuite il ya eu l'arrestation des
irlandais de vincennes ce qui vous a
valu d'être écouté par l'elysée votre
appartement fouillé vous emparer d avoir
un bouquin qui est l'un des sept
ouvrages que les publiées à ce jour
quels mots volés et ensuite au monde
vous devenez rédacteur en chef
et puis en 94 et en 96 directeur de la
rédaction
donc finalement en 26 ans le jeune
étudiant débarquer d'alger devenu quand
même le directeur de rédaction du
journal le monde voulait dire quel est
votre secret ce qu'il faut dire c'est
que dans un journal qui fonctionne comme
ça les gars l'ont ils gagnent au feu ils
viennent pas d'en haut
ouais il faut faut que ça marche
la collectivité impitoyables si ça
marche pas le mesle a raison le monde se
vend très bien ça marche bien voilà en
plus je journal le monde à vous avez une
émission la télévision une émission
exemplaires sur lci qui s'appelle le
monde des idées vous réussissez dans
cette émission à faire passer des sujets
difficiles avec beaucoup d'enthousiasmé
je trouve qu'il ya un mépris souvent à
la télé enfin deux autour de la télé
c'est qu'il ya des gens qui ouvrent leur
poste et si ils ouvrent leurs postes
qu'ils ont ils ont fait la démarche
d'aller voir et donc je pense que si on
interviews des gens si on
discute d'idées importante bon ben il
faut faut se démener pour mouiller la
chemise enthousiaste faut pas être
distant faut mouiller la chemise c'est
ce qu'on peut dire que vous avez fait
des progrès comme animateur de télé
merci parce que non même professeur pas
du tout mais c'est vrai qu'au début ce
n'était pas évident et c'était pas votre
formation du tout et vous avez fait
d'énormes progrès vous êtes le seul
animateur moustachu à la télé j'ai eu
une barbiche des petites lunettes donc
dans vos arbustes petites lunettes
trotsky bon d'accord mais j'ai gardé
leur moustache
ouais voilà ça me va ça va pas trop mal
qu'est ce que vous en pensez la
moustache est sûr c'est qu'il y ait pas
de stylo dans sa poche
ah oui oui si vous trouvez que ça fait
pitié les moustaches ophélie la
moustache la moustache ça chatouille
quand on fait des bisous yacht pendant
une période
c'est impensable que le séducteur n'est
pas débout sa vareuse l'air à la mode
l'art que toutes les mains qui ajoute
c'est vrai que la tendance les meilleurs
vous mais moi quand j'étais baba
meyrowitz et pensait alors toute façon
vous avez été trotskiste et vous dites
j'ai été trotskiste et je n'ai même été
que ça pendant dix ans de 69 à 79 en
fait vous êtes arrivé au trotskysme
plutôt pas anti colonialiste maintenant
c'est l'idée que le nord doit pas dominé
le sud
c'est une idée qui a toujours une
certaine perte est très à la mode en ce
moment
alors votre premier acte politique 767
vous avez 15 ans alger vous envoyer une
lettre à l'ambassadeur de cuba en
algérie après l'assassinât du che
guevara et c'est l'époque où vous dites
qu'il ya des phrases formidable et
plenel on se sentait convoqué par
l'histoire mondiale qui réclamait
l'ébranlement des très vieux monde
vous avez vous avez cru au messianisme
la révolution être amoureux de jean
marie messier non c'est quoi l'idée
l'idée c'est que aujourd'hui on a on a
des révoltes assez obscur obscurantistes
fondamentalistes
le antiféministe totalitaire qui nous
menace qui nous inquiète on les voit là
la cia les a laissé les a mises en place
elle les a mises en place en grande part
contre d'autres révoltes
ces révoltes celle des années soixante
dix quand on a dit trop de politique
tout ça on a bon ok c'est vrai on a fait
des bêtises on a dit des bêtises mais
ces révoltes elle était généreuse elle
était humaniste elle était féministe
elle était universaliste elle était
ouverte au monde
elle était curieuse de l'autre elle
était libertaire donc moi je veux dire
ça je veux dire que ces révoltes là et
bien on peut aujourd'hui plutôt les
regrettés voyez ça vous regrettez
finalement l'époque où on était tristes
now is communistes etc
parce qu'au moins l'ambition quels qu'en
soient les résultats l'ambition était
noble et vous dites que pour combattre
ces révoltes là ce qui était mis en
place par la cia c'est comme quand la
cia être ben laden contre les entre les
soviétiques en afghanistan c'est ça mais
on a oublié mais toute l'histoire de ben
laden ça commence avec le pakistan le
pakistan c'est le seul état des
décolonisations du siècle ça fait très
loin un autre histoire qui est un état
qui se construit sur une base religieuse
c'est l'un de ces gandhi et puis on dit
on va faire l'état des musulmans du sous
continent indien
c'est un et artificiels au départ alors
après bon ils s'arrangent ils
construisent tout de suite des régimes
militaires des régimes militaires
religieux à qui on laisse faire la bombe
atomique pourquoi pas parce qu'il ya des
soviétiques ça ça vient après mais c'est
aussi contre le tir monde contre l'un
d'eux qui est un peu neutraliste
contrebande ou mhz contre l'unfp et
qu'il ya autre chose bon donc s'étaler
theater c'est des pays non alignés en 49
ce qu'arnaud c'est les gens qui veulent
faire autre chose qui voulait qu'ils
voulaient sortir de l'idée qui est fière
d'eux de deux blocs
voilà il voulait inventer autre chose on
l'aura couper les jarrets 1
alors pourquoi le trotskisme mais pas le
communisme parce que le trotskisme et
c'est ça que j'en retiens aujourd'hui
c'est ce qui est au sein du communisme
ont critiqué le communisme c'est à dire
je pense que aujourd'hui encore il faut
toujours penser contre soi même
il faut toujours penser y compris contre
ses propres préjugés contre une course
qui s'est pensée spontanée alors c'est
quoi le trotskisme on va sortir sans
problème trotsky
des à la révolution russe notre série on
peut le dire avant toute chose chef de
l'armée rouge
inventeur des camps vue on parle
toujours de trotski comme d'un mec très
sympa théâtre au ski c'est sympa staline
c'est le méchant trotsky c'est celui qui
permet à l'union soviétique d'exister en
étant le chef de l'armée au vrai mais il
n'y a pas de trotskistes à ce moment là
alors c'est quoi le trotskisme c'est que
trotsky bombao lieu désiré de ce combat
ça et finalement ils pensent contre
lui-même peut-être pas suffisamment
il meurt en 40 assassiné par un agent de
staline dans la mer de l'air d'un coup
de piolet le deuxième il est vieux mais
il arrive à empêcher le deuxième coup de
piolet il est très fier c'est le dernier
mot qui dit à sa femme il dit j'ai
réussi à empêcher le deuxième coup à
résister jusqu'au bout
bon avec ce cette crapule parce que
c'était une crapule celui qui l'a tué
bon et donc au bout du compte que c'est
quoi la leçon de tout ça mais trotskiste
en france dans les années 30 s'est
sentie s'est senti très vite dédié r&d
variés notamment des gens qui viennent
du surréalisme des gens qui sont y pense
à côté y pense compte donc moi quelle
leçon je retiens de tout ça c'est qu'il
faut toujours penser contre il était au
coeur du communisme l'idée qu'il fallait
changer les choses ils étaient sous
influence de la révolution russe la
guerre d'espagne mais il faut penser
compte il faut penser ce qui va pas par
exemple aujourd'hui bien sûr que ben
laden c'est effroyable
bien sûr que c'est totalitaire bien sûr
que mes revers tout ce qu'on veut ok
mais en même temps contre ben laden les
bombes à fragmentation qui restent
pendant dix ans qui font plein de
petites mines dans un pays où il ya déjà
eu un million et demi de morts il ya
trois millions et demi de personnes qui
sont dehors
bon ben non la fin et les moyens ben
c'est plus compliqué la fin justifie pas
tous les moyens
il faut réfléchir aux moyens voilà ma
vue l'annoncé va me lancer non mais ce
que vous dites est très clair simplement
vous vous êtes dans un journal dont le
patron s'appelle jean marie colombani
quand il écrit en titre du journal nous
sommes tous des américains ça doit faire
un choc non il a dit nous sommes tous
américains
dans un éditorial le lendemain du 11
septembre qui à la fois c'est spontané
c'est écrit dans la nuit on a fait tous
sidérés par rapport à cet acte qui est
un crime contre l'humanité que l'anact
totalité bien sûr donc c'est le move
de solidarité instinctif mais dans la
foulée l'édito disais tout ce que je
viens de vous dire sur la note à payer 2
comment les américains ont géré cette
région du monde
bon et puis le nous sommes tous
américains il voulait dire quoi nous
sommes tous new yorkais et ckoi à new
york new york c'est le mélange c'est le
brassage c'est le métissage c'est la
rencontre d identité c'est le fait
justement on n'est pas tous chez nous
dans de petites boîtes on est citoyen du
monde et on se mêle dans le monde
new york c'est ça et c'est ce symbole là
qui a été frappé alors dans votre
bouquin vous parlez de votre trotskisme
à vous lui tirez ligue communiste
révolutionnaire il ya un autre
trotskisme celle aussi les lambertistes
c'est là où étaient jospin d'ailleurs
vous aimez pas beaucoup les lambertistes
vite c'est un peu la réincarnation des
staliniens
vous parlez même d'agressions physiques
de lambertiste du service d'ordre
lambertiste jospin pourquoi at il eu ce
trotskisme honteux j'ai écrit honteuse
souvent un peu de colère mais je dirais
vraiment c'est plutôt ça l'idée du livre
quand même c'est entre autres ce qu'ils
me malheureux j'ose pas un problème avec
sa jeunesse parce que il n'a pas pu tout
assumer publiquement il a vécu qui vais
schizophrène c'est une histoire ou
presque romanesque 1 il est un
trotskiste la nuit et sociale et ce jour
mais bon donc moi je veux dire que nono
jeunesse moi me je les vis toujours
comme des comme des enfants sains nous
nos engagements et eu souvent les
anciens lambertiste il y en a beaucoup
voilà les milieux du spectacle il ya
muraille arditi boby lapointe ils ont
ils ont un problème avec leur passé
trotskiste boby lapointe c'est nantes
tu le crois ça à vanille et framboises
sont c'est là dedans et c'est dans son
avocat ce qui chantait
et moi je les aime bien mais c'est vrai
que l'homme du devoir d'inventaire
quelque chose pas on a du mal maintenant
apprendre qu'il a caché aussi longtemps
qu'il a fait ce double j'ai aussi
longtemps oui on a du mal banc face
était en même temps un secret de
polichinelle on lui a forcé ont la force
et le monde en révélant qu'il aille il
l'a dit l'a reconnu je pense que depuis
ça le travail
c'est ça son problème c'est à dire quand
on fend l'armure vraiment ça souffre un
peu ça
il ya de la souffrance et je pense
qu'ils c'est son problème actuel moi je
pense qu'il ne sera candidat
moi c'est mon mon analyse ouais mais je
me trompe peut-être que s'il dépasse ça
que s'il arrive à rendre compte de ça il
n'y a pas à avoir honte
et puis il ya les rencontres ça le rend
plus intéressant entre nous le fait
qu'il a été plus compliqué comme ça un
peu caché tout bon on peut discuter jugé
sa moralement et tout mais ça le rend
plus complexe
c'est plus intéressant plus compliqué
que simplement un type qui a été fait
attention à ça parce qu'après ça devient
comme avec mitterrand on dit il était
formidable c'est un personnage de roman
un florentin et ça fait excuser un peu
tout les noms passés on juge sur les
actes ouais je le politique ses actes le
dernier bouquin de son directeur de
cabinet dit qu'il faut juger les
politiques comme son cocher conduit bien
où il conduit mal
ouais voilà c'est alfred de vigny en
fait est ici de ça le direction qui le
premier collaborateur de jospin a dit
voilà les politiques c'est y conduisent
bien où conduisent mal alors c'est pas
vraiment romantique ça moi je suis un
peu plus romantique c'est vrai la
question d'actualité vous pensez quoi du
du recul du soutien français à l'action
américaine en afghanistan
je pense qu'on a on a cru un moment
qu'ils allaient réfléchir qu'ils
allaient pas faire exactement la même
chose et puis hélas ils ont ils ont
répété un scénario prévu bon sincèrement
ça sert à quoi de faire des frappes
on a vu déjà bagdad on a vu déjà à
belgrade qui jamais ne sont assez
précises qui font toujours des gars à
côté sur un pays qui est un des plus
pauvres de la planète est un désert de
rio alors qu'ils ont pas aidés
l'alliance du nord qu'ils ont pas aidés
massoud
qu'ils ont pas aidé les opposants ou
talibans bon donc évidemment que bon il
ya un problème qui s'appelle ben laden
ça c'est un problème policiers c'est un
problème de recherche de renseignements
bon c'est de longue haleine mais là bon
il ya la façon dont ces menées bon les
militaires disent vous verrez le
résultat
il faudrait pas que le résultat nous
amène bon les mêmes conséquences
j'en veux continuer à aller aux usa
régulièrement à prendre l'avion à ouvrir
armes là depuis quelques quelques jours
mais oui je continuerai planche puisque
la barre à new york à peu près
s'informait du world trade center quand
ça va péter
bon il faut continuer je trouve que ce
qui est tout à fait surprenant c'est que
les américains sont devenus depuis
quelques temps un peu humble il ramenait
un plus à ramener beaucoup en disant à
tout le monde il peut rien nous arriver
on a mis au point un système imparable
et puis d'un seul coup les barres et
nous aussi on peut en décrasser oui ça
les hommes mondialisée les états unis
vivaient dominer le monde mais dans leur
monde dans le monde sera de la pire des
façons ce rappel a eu donc en effet ils
sont dans un souci du monde
bon le problème c'est qu'il faut ajuster
quand même sur sur l'asie centrale et
l'afghanistan
os qui va vous arriver c'est terrible
cette vie plenel je m'attends au pire
alors si vous avez beaucoup de travail
pas beaucoup de temps pour les dans les
boîtes de nuit
donc on va vous faire une interview un
petit peu spéciale en embauchera pendant
le jean galle
l'interview proust express spécial boîte
de nuit
mais d'abord il me faut mon dj c'est une
boîte de nuit nationaux philippe corti
sonné
voilà encore mis en boîte de nuit une
musique de boîte de nuit
voilà
et là on va faire une interview web de
mu
et puis plenel c'est quoi pour vous le
comble de la vie
or la haine
bon kai falk avait voulu plus
d'intelligence le mensonge et vélos de
faire
y'en a trop haut
quelles qualités
boucher l'homme l'amitié
et j'ai la bave
l'amitié
qui auriez vous aimé
tu me fais pas du pénal
rêvais hêtre gebara mais seulement ce
que vous détestez
l'envi le don
la musique
comment
mourir
d'un coup
quel élu sa présence
votre esprit
content
oralair
la bible
google
emma comme cela mais des dentelles
d'étayer voici benjamin biolay
benjamin biolay vous le connaissez
benjamin biolay c'est un songwriter
comme on dit maintenant producteurs
aussi et il est coauteur avec keren ann
oui mais les vues à la télévision mais
vous aviez une autre coiffure vous aviez
les cheveux plus courts et je vous ai vu
en tournée parce que je regarde beaucoup
la télé en tournée vous parliez du 10
d'henri salvador de votre prochain
disent que vous étiez en train de faire
de françoise hardy mais vous aviez les
cheveux courts et moi ça m'arrive de lui
qu il a vu de combien de temps j'ai vu
la semaine dernière à perpignan un corps
et d'esprit - propres moyens et bien un
bon ça va bien je me dirige ou et saint
louis
non mais je voudrais savoir pourquoi
edwin s'appelle edwin est vide il n'y a
pas de haine
c'est vrai non non non c'est en fait
c'est saxon il ya eu un roi
vous voulez vous voulez pas
alosi aller pendant les dix mois edwin
et dwayne appelles tu edwin edwy parce
que edwin c'est un saint celui-là on
l'oubli et à st edwin et pince il a été
roi saxons au 10ème siècle il est devenu
roi 16 ans et il est mort à 19 ans dans
la débauche après avoir épousé sa
belle-mère voilà à quoi ça sert
je pense que c'est important qu'on parle
un petit peu de benjamin qui s'est fait
un brushing pour ce soir et tous les
corps et portait un doux ce que
laisserait indivisible oui ça a été
facile d'écrire pour cette valeur
dans un premier temps pour la première
chanson ça a été facile ce que je
pensais jamais que ça aboutirait donc
c'était comme comme de rédiger un
scénario pour hollywood stories est pour
l'a déjà pour la deuxième chanson
c'était plus délicat parce qu'il était
mais vous connaissiez son oeuvre
sérieuse qu'il était très fan atiques le
très net salvador toute cette école
alors quand le disque est sorti vous
étiez en belgique en train de préparer
le veau dont on va parler et en fait on
a beaucoup parlé de keren ann et pas
beaucoup de vous et à un moment ça a dû
vous gonfle et non à mort non mais c'est
vrai non mais oui pour moi j'étais en
belgique c'était un peu je m'enfermais
pour écrire et enregistrer mon album et
j'ai complètement raté
on m'a dit tu sais que henri salvador et
multi platiné que bernadette une star
mondiale et oui je me suis bien mais
c'est bien sympa non mais j'étais pas je
me suis dis bah justement d'en parler au
ski surcroît kennedy et sur la famille
en général ça n'avait pas de temps qui
s'intéressent à cette famille en
particulier mais ils trouvent ça
charmant
j'ai entendu dans le reportage c'est
comment on fait benjamin là vous êtes
passionné d'histoire un moment où
j'étais un peu j'avoue zones y ait un
peu vous sais pas trop quoi faire et
vous aviez à beaubourg et vous cherchez
des documents sur les kennedy pas
seulement les qualités mais j'étais
désargenté au possible et je
résonnaient à la bibliothèque de
beaubourg dont je pouvais passer de
vraies mitterrand bataille de l'eau du
robinet devant delà de la pure et booste
l'eau chaude a alors benjamin oui c'est
vrai vous êtes fascinés par le mythe
kennedy par le destin shakespearien la
dynastie et c'est un concept album
autour autour de ça certaines américain
peut un peu cliché on peut dire non un
peu cliché hollywood
ouais la croisée des chemins entre le
showbiz et la politique enfin quelque
chose oui marilyn et les kennedy c'est
ça qui vous prêter serment marilyn mais
peter lefort le beau-frère du président
moubarak avec sinatra dean martin
celle ci selon survie
si peu soutenu
sous
là vous avez tous fait la parole et
musique j'ai fait la plupart des j'ai
fait tout sauf trois titres karen à la
cour composée ouais mais quand vous
travaillez avec keren ann vous fête
communale et macartney s'était dit pas
qui vous êtes toujours copain avec elle
la marge est la 13ème la
surmédiatisation de l'été vous c'était
juste un moment un petit peu délicat à
passer on n'était pas prêts en fait un
succès aussi important ce n'était pas
une autre en même temps mais on en a
quand même les répercussions et êtes
tranquilles financièrement maintenant
moi ça va chercher mec avec terrasse qu
alors on fait tout ça vient le concept
album l'idée vient de melody nelson que
vous avez entendu vous êtes d'ailleurs
présent le 10 de gainsbourg
ça vous a fasciné c'est un grand choc
pour vous ça m'a fasciné
j'avais d'abord découvert aux armes et
caetera un qui était le premier 10
français que j'ai vraiment écoutés mais
pas de mélodie steduto cover et voyage
était fasciné par le son du reggae et
tout mais melody nelson m'a amené
ailleurs ouais et alors vous avez écrit
depuis l'âge de 14 ans à peu près 500
chansons ouais mais des daubes
abdominale abord à huy avons écrit 350
truc épouvantable
ouais vous avez l'oreille absolue c'est
à dire que quand vous entendez une
chanson vous entendez toutes les notes
avant je l'avais plus c'était très
pénible que j'allais écouter un concert
de musique classique j'entendais toutes
les notes c'est fini ça je serai à jesse
louis pourquoi dieu soit loué c'est un
cauchemar alors est en concert le 12
novembre à l'olympia dans le cadre du
festival des arts hoc
et puis on va vous faire une petite
interview
technicolor puisque vous êtes fascinée
par hollywood
on ne bouge pas pendant le singer
qu'est ce qui vous rend vert de rage
l'ennui c'est un chien bleu de peur
de devoir parler devant des gens que je
connais pas c'est vrai ce qui vous rend
rose de bonheur le sexe est ce qui vous
fait rire jaune les gens fils tendance à
se rabaisser pour montrer à quel point
ils sont superbes la fausse modestie ni
fausse modestie pardon ah oui d'accord
ce qui vous rend rouge de honte d'être
mal coiffée comme ça je vais réflexion
ça
comme annoncé au blind test spécial
girls band
j'appelle un homme dessus de tout
soupçon pour arbitrer ce blind test
magie à philippe corti
là
bon
à
cortina pas de culotte bien attention
donc girlsband je veux le nom des
interprètes didier attention chance au
numéro un
beaucoup
ça
suprême non ben c'est gilles paquet
brenner qui a trouvé ça fait un point
pour cette équipe la numéro 2 didier
ce genre de mec du volant sont les jurés
teboul non mais attendez
tu as des as titia du calme sinon il ya
des amis voilà
didier
aujourd'hui mon gars
3 0 pour les masters je crois qu'il va
revenir pour les masters les attentions
didier web
mes filles du calme comment vous pouvez
connaître ça c'est le premier gang band
de notre génération
vous l'avez reconnu à la première note
aaa je l'attendais celle que je vois
déjà pas mal pour cette attention
ophélie a pour se réveiller mais là
attention
didier cucchi
tu aimais ce qu'elles font attention si
lors de replay elle joue droite
il ya soufflage quoi ça sert
c'est le mercier donc c'est catherine
barma me dis que seulement
c'est toi
dans toute façon bien combien mais vimla
1,4 très bien continue dj fiche
où s'est perdue car j'avais lâché
encore jeune indignée
bon
comment vous savez ce à quoi vous avez
fait des fumées ouais c'est bien il a
faim beau film est gagnable un
appartement est en train de planter tout
le monde il a ainsi déjà vues en continu
dédié
joli show est en train de faire ce qu'on
apprend comment j'ai pu travailler
il a fait un cavalier seul en a marqué 7
points
didier
pas
bidon c'est pas mignon
j'aime c'est énorme non mais ils sont là
connaître moi je connais les parisiens
parisienne c'est très bizarre ce qui est
en train d'arriver
elle avait une boule de feu
je demanderai au public de ne pas
souffler si l'enjeu de faire évacuer la
salle ou de faire déshabiller kalia oui
didier
attention je touche pas une bille
franchement il ya peut-être un truc pour
toi lapin
mais c'est noël s'est elle sait qu'elle
doit venir ça tu te mets pas à côté moi
tu te mets deux bouts là autour seul
debout et avait de regarder la bombe et
les mains sur la tête
voilà plus haut bien attention ça tu
peux savoir plus
ça tu peux savoir didier
d'ici peu aussi
gilles paquet brenner quand elles des
abers et des casques sur le diplôme ans
avait gagné cinq fois plus que ça et
plus que ça je les 10 points
mais qu'est ce qui se passe là bas on a
parlé de musique alors qu'on peut vue de
faire actionner des petites bosses sans
doute et si c'était tout moment par
l'émission pas tous les jours
lambie sexe magouille et culture
générale
rober winter gilles paquet brenner pour
les jolies choses de gilles
paquet-brenner avec marion cotillard
stomy bugzy patrie de l titoff le 14
novembre en salles valérie lemercier du
11 au 15 décembre
l'indien en tournée le 6 novembre à
clermont ferrand les 8es vichy les
nouvelles vers lévis à bourges et après
à la rochelle
rosberg capitaine de l'om mérite sont
devenus des campagnes télévisées
jean yanne
joyal je suis à l'être explique au
cherche midi éditeur
merci jean victoria beckham le 6
novembre sont dix ans ventre et ça
s'appelle libye voilà et le single
s'appelle notre and in some girls fbi
pennel secret de jeunesse prix médicis
de l'essai et c'est chez stock merci
vous demande d'être venu voilà on
continue
la jama violet rose kennedy le single
s'appelle aussi risqué mais du grand
concert le 12 mai
à l'olympia et le 18 décembre à l'elysée
montmartre et pour finir un petit mot
gentil monsieur philippe corti vivre là
quand iberia
prochaine
non
c'est moins qu'en mai
il
je vais voir
jusqu'où
tu as
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linda hardy tube abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu